at the end of time
[Music]
13 o'clock
hey everybody what's going on
oh he's like right in the middle yeah
[__] I'm [__] up with you getting
talking to other people and [__] we'll
see that's what I mean you have to like
yeah
you have to know what time the [__] is
and what yeah prepare accordingly so is
this light okay or is it too bright or
what it was way too bright earlier and I
turned I think it went off it looks like
it's okay I mean it looks okay so
they're running that and then getting
rid of that one we can do that for this
show yeah yeah okay yeah I just turned
that one off there because it seemed
kind of glaring but uh yeah so hey
everybody happy Wednesday night uh yeah
yeah because that's gonna drive that's
gonna drive me crazy all right but yeah
so uh this is gonna be kind of a
Grimm show this evening no the serial
killer show yeah I mean I know this is
like a weird thing to say but
these ones uh are not I don't know I
guess because I'm really interested in
True Crime and really interested in
serial killers like for some reason
these are
a lot easier for me to research I don't
know what it is I guess because I'm just
like more interested in all the stuff
but and this guy
it's really strange to me that um this
had actually been in the rotation for a
while
um and I don't remember if one of you
guys like uh recommended it or something
like that but this is a guy that doesn't
really get talked about all that much
even though
I mean basically he was like the Ted
Bundy before Ted Bundy you know what I
mean he's like he's not the original
Night Stalker
he's the original [__] Bundy pretty
much like it's like the you know like
his victim profile and like the way he
went about things like his pathology
seems very similar to Ted Bundy but this
guy was operating before Ted Bundy maybe
it's because this dude he's still alive
by the way he's serving a life sentence
in uh prison in Michigan
but it might be because he was
technically only convicted of one murder
because that was the one that they had
the most evidence on but they're pretty
sure that he did at least seven
um and you know but they just didn't
have enough uh you know evidence to get
him on those and they wanted to get him
off the streets so they did
um I watched a couple documentaries
about this and I read a book about it
that came out in the 70s
uh that's just called the Michigan
murders and it's actually really good so
it gave like a lot more background
although one weird thing that it did I
guess it's not that weird like
considering but one weird thing that it
did was that it changed everyone's names
which I think the only names that it
didn't change were maybe like some of
the investigators and stuff that worked
on it but it changed all the victims
names it changed the alleged killer's
name and I just thought that was really
strange so when I was reading it I was
just kind of like had to be like okay
well which person is he talking about
now because that's not the person's real
name so I had to keep like looking it up
but other than that there's like a lot
of really good details about there and
it's actually if you have Kindle
unlimited you can read it for free
because that's how I read it so if
you're interested in more details about
the case then uh then you can read it
because I just kind of
sped right like over the last day or so
like while we were getting ready for the
show but yeah I was telling Tom a little
bit about it yesterday and then he told
me to stop talking about it because he
was bumming him out yeah
we were in the [__] uh Chinese buffet
weren't we no no no no no we were we
were getting ready to we were getting we
were like we were streaming yeah we were
on the streaming yeah we were on [__]
stream mating [__]
I'm trying to stay rocked up
no no stop talking about it
trying to throw me out of it I wasn't
really I was just like making
conversation trying yeah but yeah
[__] erection killer
I'll talk about that [__] well I mean
that's a good sign though because it's
like it would be like really [__] up
if you talk about that if I started
talking about that and you were like oh
tell me more yeah and then you've got
all yeah but you know the what we worked
this morning man it's a wild [__] way
down but we can't talk about it here
it's pretty good we had a pretty good
morning we did yeah it's like like I
said it's kind of like slow but it but
it goes but um but yeah it's once you
start one like a lot of other people
started jumping in yeah you open up a
show in private and all of a sudden all
these other dudes start shopping we had
like six or seven with like suggestions
oh damn
camera in my hands with a light on it
you know what I mean I'm being a
cameraman and [__] getting involved
and [__] and they're trying to tell me
what to do and it's all conflicting
and I'll be in too much in the shot and
[__] you might be bi but these other
dudes are probably you know straight
they're just looking at her so I don't
want to get involved into them
in the shot you know what I mean but
it's just technical issues man yeah well
technically we're working it out yeah we
tomorrow we're just ignoring them now
we'll probably do like most of the day
tomorrow because we don't have you know
we have to do we don't have anything
else going on well that's not that I
know of unless I get some other job or
something like that early in the morning
yeah but we'll see we're getting to
where we're not we're not drinking in
there because we did the math and we
drink during all the [__] we'd be alkies
in about a month yeah big time so well
yeah if we're gonna start doing that
like pretty much every day it's like
obviously yeah right you can't get too
much it is kind of nice to have one or
two because it kind of loosens you up a
little bit but it's like yeah we can't
really get in the habit of doing that
still gonna drink on this [__] though
yeah I can drink on these shows yeah
because this is like let me go make sure
the ice is
okay I mean I think it was but we have
enough water supply I do not know I did
not look
but yeah so like I said I'm not really
sure why this dude isn't better known
there are like some uh documentaries
about it on YouTube not all I you know I
don't really want to say this but a lot
of them weren't super I couldn't watch
all of them but
there was one that um that was actually
pretty good that used a lot of news
footage and stuff like that from the
times it was like contemporary
and that was really interesting too
because that had all of the um you know
people that worked on the case and it's
like and then it showed you like the
crime scenes like or not you know not
the anything like horrible or anything
like that but it just kind of showed you
where this stuff happened so it really
kind of gave you a a better you know
better handle on it and you know I
thought Tom might find this interesting
because he lived in Michigan for a while
and uh he had never heard of this either
but it was a well a little bit before
his time I guess this happened from
1967 and 1969.
a two-year period and like the first
ones that he did like he did one and
then allegedly and allegedly uh he did
one and then it was like a year before
he did another one but then like it
started picking up like they would get
like closer together
so yeah
um well hey Pokey what's up all right so
do we have anything else anything we
need to talk about before we get into
the main thing uh no I don't think so
I mean you know
first 10 15 minutes is just mostly a
warm-up and anything making sure
everybody's coming in getting into the
show yeah like a little intro yeah so uh
no I I think they're here
yeah so every like murder Hornets here
Sebastian's here Ben's here Tammy's here
okay like you know because most of the a
lot of the regulars are here yeah so
that's good just let it roll yeah now um
are you familiar with uh you know you've
lived in Michigan for a while are you
familiar with Ann Arbor or Ypsilanti yep
that's about where most of these took
place although one of the victims uh
that he allegedly killed
um was in Salinas California
and uh we'll get into that
too and something too that was
interesting is one victim that um gets
brought up a lot in the tally somebody
else actually got convicted of that one
murder which they pretty much suspected
from the beginning they weren't entirely
sure if it was the same purp or not
um but they found out later on through
DNA that it wasn't but all the other
ones were almost certainly the same guy
because the ammo was very very similar
and um and I'm just warning yeah it's
this one's a little rough good like um
how the how the victims were found and
stuff like that because this dude was a
[__]
monster all right I'm imagining he still
is a monster even though he is never
confessed he still maintains that he is
innocent of all charges and
um and apparently some of his family
does too
I don't know what to make of that
but I don't know the details yeah I mean
you'll see when when they get when we
get into like the evidence and stuff and
I know this was like late 60s so they
didn't have DNA they didn't have all
that other kind of stuff but I think
they're what I mean in the aggregate I
think there was
um you know sufficient circumstantial
evidence to be like yeah it's it's
almost like 99 It's gotta be this guy
you know what I'm saying yep
um even though he only got convicted of
one
so yeah as I mentioned uh this is
generally called the Michigan murders
although this guy has also been called
The Co-Ed Killer or the ipsilanti Ripper
I've heard him called that as well and
like I said this is a series of seven
murders uh you know six of those taking
place in Michigan one of them taking
place in California which they're pretty
sure are this [__] now all of
the victims were young women uh the
youngest was 13. although most of them
were University students so they were
like in the early 20s like late teens
early 20s
and um all of them were pretty much
either like kidnapped or they were
picked up like you know like Ted Bundy
would do where he'd be like hey you want
to ride somewhere you know it was the
late 60s everyone was hitchhiking and
[__] like that so he would pick them up
that like that usually
um and then he would take them to some
remote location
and um do really horrible [__] to them
uh usually rape them usually uh torture
them usually beat them uh really really
badly and then usually murder them
usually strangulation or stabbing
although he did shoot a couple of them
among doing all of the other things now
I know this is his pattern because some
of them survived they did not okay just
when they found the bodies there were
signs of all that yes okay yes all right
no one survived this dude no
um the only people that survived were
people that uh you know because it was
one thing that he would do was he would
kind of cruise around being like hey you
want to ride or you know like approach
women in the street and stuff and pretty
much the only people that survived were
like uh yeah no yeah people said no well
they didn't go through the they didn't
go through his take his [__]
techniques so we don't know
exactly how he did that I was always
fascinated of how they did that how they
actually committed it I was like one of
the things that really upsetted me about
the damn toolbox Murders yeah because
some of it was recorded and there's
transcripts of it that describe what had
happened some of it
and those dudes are [__] these
dirtbags man beyond big time
and you looked at him you go you [__]
Dirtbag yeah I mean I just look at a
dude yeah
see but that's what's creepy about this
dude is that much like Ted Bundy this
dude looked completely clean cut yeah
normal most people said he acted real
normal
um you know he was in high school he was
like a star athlete he was like
co-captain the football team just like a
jock type he was baseball player he was
all and um you know his pick of the
girls well and well and that's the weird
thing is that he did like even his
roommates because he was in a frat and
everything and like and his roommates
would say man he was real good with the
ladies like sometimes he'd come home uh
you know over the weekend and he'd have
like two or three of them yeah you know
what I mean then he'd like take him in
his room yeah well that just means that
he was uh
somehow compartmentalized where he had a
normal side a player side but then there
was something wrong with him where he's
uh really sexually sadistic see and what
he really wants to do
they're not gonna let him do they can't
cut pieces of them off or something like
that and and you know no woman's gonna
put it with that
uh yeah no so he's taking he's taking
the he's getting the cream you know
talking about he's growing up getting
the cream
uh just the best of the best
but that's not enough for him that's not
what he's satisfied that's not what he's
fantasizing about he's trying to take it
to another level
beyond the BDSM is BDSM until someone
dies
all right uh yeah if you ask me
this is worse than a dirtbag
that's even worse yeah
you don't even have if if this is how it
went we're gonna find out
if you had everything all the good [__]
life had to offer and then you even
wanted to do this so you're not doing it
out of hatred you're doing it because
you're [__] spoiled because you got
this weird Kink oh no that makes you
even worse I can kind of understand it
better when
dude lived a miserable life and was
[__] [__] with his whole time and
he just became a ball of hatred I can
understand that yeah it's like you don't
even own it you don't condone it but you
do understand you still gotta die right
but I understand I I still understand
but yeah [__] like this are
even more mystifying because it would
seem like you said he was a good looking
dude uh he was athletic like I said
didn't really seem to have any trouble
getting girlfriends um you know he was a
college student he everyone said he was
very intelligent and actually the only
thing they said he was mostly normal
although
um some people did say that under
certain circumstances like he had a real
quick temper and they were like so much
so that they were like uh flabbergasted
by it because they he just seemed so
normal and gentle and everything like
that but it's like he could turn on a
dime and get like this like uh a real
violent temper yeah um even though a lot
of his friends didn't say that but some
of his friends did say that they had
seen him act like that into that it
surprised them that doesn't make you a
serial killer though no no but I just
have that and they're not doing this but
I'm just saying that's pretty much
that's the only thing that well that was
the only thing that people knew about
him like at the time they found out some
[__] about him I'm getting the feeling
just from the back just from his back
story the background that you're giving
me right now what you're dealing with is
a dude
that thinks he deserves more than what
he has and he already has everything so
that was a huge ego huge yeah
and he's got some kind of a sexual
sadistic streak in him
that somehow was there I don't know if
it's genetics or who knows could be that
it was easy for him to get women so
therefore he turns on them like they're
all hoes you know it might have been
something it might have been something
like that well the weird thing about it
was that it seems like like he didn't
have his childhood didn't seem to have
been abusive or anything like that now
his mom uh was a single mother again the
the thing was where she would kind of
like hook up with a dude and then he
would turn out to be like an abusive
drunk or something like that and then
she would like you know dump him or he
would take off or whatever so after a
while she just said [__] it and um you
know she just became a single mom he had
two siblings and a interesting thing was
that this his sister and I can't
remember what her name is but um her
sister I think was maybe older but she
got into some spot of trouble she like
got pregnant when she was really young
or something like not real young but she
was like an older teenager and that
um basically he just wrote off his
sister he you just called her a [__]
and thought she was a disgusting [__]
and [__] like that so he almost had this
weird kind of because we'll find out
later on too he had a thing about he did
not believe that women should have their
ears pierced because the holes like
messed up their bodies and he was super
disgusted by women's periods that too so
kind of weird Madonna horror complex
yeah it definitely does seem like that's
kind of what this [__] had going
on because they yeah we'll get into that
a little bit he's real egotistical he
doesn't have any problem getting women
um sees them
Economist disposable
uh doesn't like part certain parts of
female behavior and kind of more he
thinks he's more moral than them yeah I
got that impression part of female
behavior is immoral so therefore they
deserve punishment something like that a
lot
part of the you know
men and women have [__] weird ways of
looking at each other you can't really
as a as a man you cannot judge a woman's
thought process by male values they're
very different
um because they're seeing the world
through different eyes that they're not
seeing through male eyes well generally
priorities are very different there our
experiences are quite different here's
an example
you can have a girl
who's she's single she's in a club
this is actually somebody I know told me
this story I checked it with Jenny I
probably used it before on the show
she's single she's at a club she's
lonely
she sees a guy who's okay
but she's not exact he's not exactly the
kind of she's not exactly the guy that
she's looking for
she kind of lowers the bar a little bit
to go home with this guy and they have a
thing it might last a week or so
but then it doesn't work out and then
he's gone
she's back at the same Club
she sees another guy who she likes
she raises the bar and makes it harder
for that dude
he's now got to prove himself to her
because she likes him because she likes
them and she sees that maybe going
somewhere so the dude [__] Chomps all
the hurdles and jumps through all the
Rings and [__] gets her
[__] he's like damn this must be a
high that very valuable woman man it
took me a week to get in these drawers
so he's back at the club and uh his
buddy says oh you're going out with her
and he goes yeah yeah she was she's uh
[__] tough not to crack but I [__]
oh for you for a week I was chasing it
oh her oh she's easy [__] I [__] her
on the first date just here for a couple
weeks back and it was that dude right
well he's gonna be like what the [__]
what the f what he's gonna but to me
that makes completely into and like we
talked about this and I said that makes
complete sense I explained yeah but not
to that guy well no that's right I've
been tricked you know to a girl she must
he she must not like me or free because
she raised the bar on me she must like
this dude that's what his first thing
that he would jump that's that's the
conclusion yeah that's exactly the
opposite and it's the opposite but you
see you're looking through it through a
male's eyes because it's easy to [__] a
guy if you're a woman
all right you know all you gotta share
some interest you know yeah if you show
some answers you're nice
if he's single and he's got nothing to
do this
priors are totally different and then
there's the thing of hypergamy most of
the women are chasing the top 10 of the
guys the rest of them get kind of top 20
percent of the guys the rest of them get
kind of cut out so they see all these
women going for the guys that have more
to offer which kind of they're like oh
[__] those [__] you know what I mean
but they would do the same thing if they
were women they wouldn't go out for the
average guy the average guy doesn't have
much to offer they're going to go for
the above average that's what kind of
pisses me off it's like dudes are always
like whining about this that because
it's about women doing this or that I'm
like you [__] do the same thing what
are you [__] crying about no no they
don't do the same thing the average guy
will [__] a below average woman or an
average woman that doesn't mean he'll
stay with her well yeah but I mean but
women don't do the same thing right it's
just the priorities women have more to
lose yeah than guys do from it and
um no matter what or something just
ingrained in a woman she wants a guy who
has higher status than him that makes
more money and people like him you know
they very rarely go out with a guy that
makes less money for them and is less
popular than them they're not a catch
okay
so these forces that go on some of these
six [__] like possibly this dude they
can't grasp that
they may be on the in that top 20
percent actually getting women
but then they don't they devalue these
women in their own mind well look at
what look at how they are
but these are all [__] they're not
worth it this definitely came across as
a [__] probably what you're
talking about with this type he seems
very even though some of his girlfriend
because they did like after all the [__]
came out they did interview like several
of his girlfriends or like girls he had
dated
um some of them just couldn't say enough
nice about him they said oh he was he
was lovely you know we never you know we
just kind of drifted apart or whatever
um some of them did come up with some
crazy [__] about him but not really so
he did seem to know how to behave
himself around
most women but it did seem like I don't
know if it just happened that like he
would get one woman and she just like
made him mad somehow or something and in
something just like [__] snapped in
his brain it seemed like because like I
said his roommates used to say he used
to bring like these real hot like you
know big tittied women you know they
didn't say big titty back in the 60s but
they would say well built or something
like that they were attacked stacked
yeah that that was one word that they
used in that book but yeah it feels like
he would always and his roommate like I
said said we were all like God damn dude
like he would come in with like two or
three of them like sometimes in the
weekend like take him up to the room you
know what I mean he was a band right
before we get before we get too far away
from the subject
if you're listening to this program and
you're a man chances are your average
just because you're an average man
doesn't mean you're going to be a loser
you have chosen to be an average man you
chose this you may just not understand
it but do your research read [__]
Musashi everything you do and everything
you are is because you made a series of
choices all right
if you don't want to in the eyes of an
average woman the average man is
invisible
so what you want to do is you don't want
to be average you have to become visible
you become visible by a TV status
achieve success you're not going to the
gym not like that not like that POA Pua
thing where they're just like oh wear a
silly hat or wear some crazy clothes
you'll stand don't don't do that no
that's even worse
then you just look like a dork yeah
John's like mystery or whatever that
[__] dude's name I want a group of
dudes they're badasses make dude friends
and bro friends and [__] go work out
and go do good [__] and build a good
status with men and [__] make money
and [__] dress sharp the way women
like you you like women to dress the way
you dress jerking it to that damn porn
and then [__] outfits that they got
on you say oh that's why they should
look what about you how are you going to
look we'll see they never think
they don't think they got to do it
thousands me and Jen to be in the club
in some little [__] five foot two
dude talking [__] about a woman he could
never get and I'm looking at what he's
wearing like a dude you look like a
[__] toad
what you're wearing has no [__] style
at all okay so
a lot of brothers know exactly what I'm
talking about you gotta look right for
the target market or whatever kind of
woman you're trying to attract you don't
go to a Golf Club dress like a tennis
pro you're gonna get [__] laughed out
of there but that tennis pro outfit you
go to a [__] Country Club you'd
probably do well yeah everything happens
read the room fit there's rules there's
rules of [__] you're not gonna go into a
biker bar dress like a [__] golf kid
and [__] get any respect from that
women you better shut up and looking
like a [__] biker okay it applies
everywhere you can't be a scholar and
dress like a dude from Harvard and go
hang out with the [__] Mongols or the
[__] or the [__] warlocks and get
respect with them they're gonna [__]
hate you you know they're just gonna
take your [__] and the women are gonna
laugh at you so it's just that's the
rules so just because your average you
chose to be average you don't have to be
average be improve yourself become
visible
well we you know they do it at almost
any age I think we talked about that a
lot when we were talking about like that
[__] Elliot Roger [__]
because we got all we got all into like
Big Town yeah that kind of crap and
here's another thing just because you
have the visuals
that that doesn't mean they're gonna
[__] take you
you could have the right height you
could be six feet tall you could have
the money you could have a six pack you
could be wearing the right clothes if
you open in your if you open your mouth
they don't like what's coming out of it
you're off the list your appearance just
gets you in the door
yeah yeah you gotta have some [__] to
back that up too I'm just saying yep
like I said I've said this lots of times
if you're some [__] rich kid from the
Middle East you can pull up in a [__]
Bugatti or Ferrari or whatever those
girls aren't gonna [__] give a [__]
if you're a dick
if you're cool then you know yeah but
chances are
you know you have a guy from Saudi
Arabia pull up Assad's probably listen
to my buddy from sorry if you pull up in
a [__]
Supercar okay your foreign
you know because there's stories you
know well honestly anytime I see a dude
pull up in a car like that I'm always
like what's wrong with that dude what is
he what is he compensating for well that
might be a cheap car for him because
they got so much money right but women
are stupid they know yeah this mother
[__] loaded it's a little sauce I'm
gonna go and give up the give up the
snatch to this dude and he's gonna stay
no he's gonna run right through you he's
got [__] hundreds of girls like you
yeah a lot of the girls are just like I
said we're not we're not dumb nope
they're not dumb
oh you've seen that [__] yeah we know
what that we know what that's about yep
we know what that's about I don't know
are they do they think they're
impressing other dudes because I don't I
mean I would hate to think they're
impressing women because they're not
impressing other dudes I think it's
probably that uh they're fantasizing
that they're impressing women but
they're mostly impressing other dudes
yeah because it's like muscularity it
doesn't really impress women they
they're they're attracted but it doesn't
really impress them impress mostly dudes
yeah
well I mean I think the same thing kind
of applies like a lot of times if women
like get real dressed up and like [__]
like that to go out it's not so much
because they want a bunch of like dudes
ogling them it's like they kind of want
to look good compared to like other
women or they want other women to be
like oh you look hot you know what I
mean it's that kind of thing
two equal dudes all things being equal
one dude so I could really scrawny or
fat the other guy's [__] semi-jacked
she's gonna take the Jack guy
you know if everything else being equal
yeah I mean if they're both yeah if
they're if they're about everything else
right like
if the Jack dude is a douche yeah that's
not being equal then that's not equal
yeah that's what I'm saying right but
yeah so uh okay so we seem to have
wandered far afield so early in the show
we're talking about what this
motherfucker's motivations is I'm over
maybe and like I said I'm psychic
[__] I'm not sure because I did read
a little bit about his childhood but as
I said it didn't seem I'm not saying
that it wasn't abusive because like I
said his mom did kind of go through a
couple of husbands that seemed like
abusive drunks that took off so yeah
that's traumatic and everything but I
don't know I don't know it doesn't
really seem like his pathology is
came from like a traumatic kind of
childhood he really seems to have some
kind of like really wildly misogynistic
uh kind of thing going on that
is usually keeps it pretty low-key he's
able to kind of like cover it up
but you know it comes out when he's
frustrated or when he gets angry about
something and like I said when we talk
about what he did to some of these women
um
it's um you know how that you know they
say Overkill yeah
um yeah because this is a rage monster
yeah and this is like um well and I
don't even know if I'd so much call it
that because it seemed in a lot of ways
to be somewhat calculated like the
torture that he did
um and he had a weird thing too where he
would come back to the Bodies Okay so
he's uh he's a necrophile I don't well
yeah they're not entirely sure because
they're like well some of the women that
were you know they know they were raped
but they weren't sure if they were raped
while they were still alive or after
they were dead so there could be a
necrophile when you look at Ridgeway and
some of the other ones when they're and
even even with Buddy when they went back
to a body it was because it was for free
yeah I mean I'm kind of thinking that's
probably why Ridgeway was such a piece
of [__] they'd be rotten and he'd I
can't understand that
well I kind of feel like that might have
happened here too because this dude
Collins
um
he kept them somewhere and then he would
dump them and then he would go back to
like look at kept him alive
no okay kept him dead for a while like
for a little like a few days okay and
then he would go and dump them someplace
he's using him as a sex doll probably of
course yeah so I'm kind of assuming now
they think that they know that some of
them were raped while they were still
alive but um but they they're not sure
because the thing is by the time they
usually found the bodies they were like
real decomposed right so because we dump
them outside
and then they would find them you know
what I mean
so yeah if I didn't mention it this
guy's name is John Norman Collins
although he's also known as John Norman
Chapman although I'm not going to call
him that because he only changed his
name and I don't even know what the
legalities of all this are he changed
his name because he was trying to get I
don't even remember what what the deal
with this was he was trying to get
extradited or something like that like
to Canada like to be imprisoned in
Canada because he thought and so I
thought he was just like oh so changing
his name was gonna have to I don't know
what all the all the thing about that
but you know what I mean so that's kind
of like he it didn't work like I said
he's still in prison they were like yeah
you're not going anywhere Bud uh so I'm
not gonna call him by that name even
though that technically is I guess his
legal name now but he's mostly known by
John Norman Collins because that was the
name that he was uh born under so he was
actually picked up um a week after the
last murder that he committed and
honestly the [__] the story of like
how they caught him is kind of crazy
because they kind of had him
I don't know if they necessarily had him
on their radar like they brought him in
like on one of the earlier cases but
they kind of dismissed him and this just
kind of goes to show and especially
probably more so back in the 60s
because you know there was a whole thing
about like oh all the hippies and all
those troublemakers on the college
campuses and [__] like that so a guy
that was like super clean cut like he
was like he had real short hair and he
was just like real you know and he
seemed real personable and uh you know a
little bit conservative and stuff like
that so
um they probably didn't think that
anybody like that such a nice young man
could do something like this
um so I think that maybe
uh that might have helped him out too
like he kind of went under the rainbow
uh you know under the radar because he
didn't really look like
somebody that would do this kind of [__]
you know
so it may be that but yeah so he was put
in prison in 1970 and he's still there
like I said he's still alive I'm not
sure how old he is he looks like crap
now but like I said I will admit he was
like a good looking dude like back in
the old day old days
um and I can see how
he wouldn't have had problems getting
women but yeah so this is probably like
the worst [__] person you could even
have to upload a picture of him he's on
the um the thumbnail he's on the
thumbnail and that's like right after
like that was when they arrested him
that picture I think
um but yeah so five murders that they're
pretty sure attributed plus the sixth
one that took place in California when
he was actually on vacation out there
but yeah we'll get into that
so the first known victim of this
allegedly of this uh Collins person
was a 19 year old young woman her name
was Mary fledger I think is how you
pronounce her last name at least I saw a
documentary and that was how they
pronounced it so I'm assuming that
that's correct
um she went to Eastern Michigan
University almost most of the victims
actually went to Eastern Michigan
University or uh whatever the other one
was like University of Michigan I guess
like in those two
cities
um so she was last seen on July 9th
1967. uh a neighbor saw her walking
toward her apartment in Ypsilanti now
one thing that the neighbor did remember
they said while she was walking and it
was kind of like evening while she was
walking back to her apartment the
neighbor said that he see he saw this
kind of clean-cut looking young man in a
kind of a bluish gray Chevy like kind of
driving alongside her
and it seemed as though like he couldn't
hear what the guy signed but it seemed
as though the guy was maybe trying to
get her to like trying to pick her up or
like you're trying to get her to get in
the car he said so he's like so he saw
her like two times like you know he
stops and like says something and she
shakes her head and keeps walking like
trying to ignore the dude and then he
pulled up along again and like said
something else to her and she again like
shook her head and kept walking and then
the neighbor said at that point like he
couldn't see them anymore because they
like turned to corner or something like
that so he didn't know what happened uh
after that
so uh what happened after that
unfortunately was I don't know if she
eventually got into the car with him
willingly or if he forced her into the
car when no one was looking
um but later on uh they actually found
uh her body it was almost a month later
it was on August 7th like two teenage
boys found her
um it was like on an abandoned Farm like
out in a field
well she was last seen in early July
like July 9th 1967. and then they found
her on August 7th so they stopped her
body she's taken yeah right as hell yeah
so yeah so when they found her like the
two boys well here's the [__] up thing
like in the book like the two boys that
found her they thought at first they
couldn't even tell that it was a person
they weren't actually even sure it was a
person okay um they thought it was a
deer at first but then they saw
something I think they saw like an ear
or like part of a hand or something like
that and they were just like oh [__] and
then they had to like go and call the
cops you know what I mean it must have
been balled up or something
um I don't think it was but it was like
just they said it was just I mean this
is [__] up but they describe it like
pretty well in the book
um where it was just kind of like black
and like you couldn't even tell like
they're like the top part of it was just
like black and like all sloft off and
yeah
[__] like that it was like real nasty
but so um so yeah they brought her in
they um identified her through dental
records they were able to do that like
the following day
and they found out the pathologist that
she had been stabbed 30 times
in uh the chest and like in her abdomen
like stomach area
um you know with a knife or something
like that
um her feet had been cut off just above
the ankle
and some of her fingers including a
thumb on one hand uh were also missing
also one of her forearms had also been
cut off
um these body parts were never found
they also found evidence
that
um she had been beaten quite excessively
with a blunt object before she died also
well at the head yeah usually like
around the The Head and the um breasts
he was real breast centered like he
would usually do [__] up [__] yeah
fish yeah like he would cut them or beat
them with a strap or something like that
and now
no um broken skulls where the skulls
fractured was he or some of them were
yeah some of them were I don't know I
don't think this woman's was but some of
the later ones were not hitting her with
something heavy
but some of the later ones he did yeah
okay but I think he changed it up a
little bit like the mo was close enough
that they knew this was probably the
same dude but he did kind of change it
up a little bit sometimes
probably knocking her out
maybe something maybe keeps hitting her
in the head and then [__] knock her
out and they do stuff and then she'd
[__] need and hit her again and knock
her back out
probably something like that
no proof that the
the the legs in the arm will probably
cut off pose more than I think
possibly
although as I said with some of the
later victims um um it appeared that he
had
bound them and like tortured them okay
so it's possible that she was still
alive when that happened to her they're
not entirely sure
um because where they found her that
wasn't where she was killed right uh
which was the case with almost all of
the victims like he killed them
elsewhere and then dumped them someplace
else they didn't have they didn't have
uh the crime scene yeah I mean some of
them they did find them later they did
this one she was killed
um they well yeah the later they find
out yeah they found out later okay they
found out later
so yeah so she had been beaten really
badly
um they couldn't tell because she was
too decomposed they couldn't tell if she
had been raped although they presumed
that probably she had been probably yeah
yeah
now um they were able to determine from
Footprints and drag marks and stuff like
that that the body had been moved at
least three times during the month
before it had been found
they thought that the first place that
the body was was kind of like on this
pile of like old like trash like bottles
and cans and stuff that was like behind
this cops of trees
um so it had been there for some time
and then it looked as though it had been
dragged like five feet into a field
and then it lay there for a long time
just like exposed to the elements and
then not too long before the body was
discovered it looked like the dude had
come back and dragged the body three
feet further they're not sure if he was
trying to make it like so she was found
easier because that will that
that came into play like later on where
they were pretty sure that like one girl
was murdered and then like her body was
you know kind of stowed someplace and
then he put it somewhere where he knew
people would find it three feet isn't
very much it's not that yeah it's not it
may have been from Rolling it over not
so much movement it just rolled her over
to the other side to do something and
then roll her keep rolling her over
but there's also a chance there no that
that might have been done by animals but
there was no animal
no sign yeah because in the book they
kind of said well it's like it was a
possibility it could have been done by
animals but the fact that they found
like human Footprints like in their
something that looked like human
Footprints and the fact like the way
that the drag marks were they said they
suspected that the killer had come back
and like moved the stuff around
yeah and I think then three feet that's
not much I know I know yeah but I think
that at least the first five foot
movement I'm pretty sure they were they
were sure that that was at least a
person that had done that
and they and you know as we'll see like
later on they did suspect that he
returned to at least one of the crime
scenes because they think they saw him
but it was first on top of something and
they moved it yeah like on a pile it was
like yeah so he couldn't be seen having
sex with it probably maybe
I mean I kind of imagine that that's
probably what he may have not been there
that long when he did that yeah I don't
know like I said it was a month so yeah
from he's going back to relive it or
something to see it yeah and
speaking of reliving it
a couple of days after Mary Fletcher's
body was identified
a dude wonder who it could be
turned up at the funeral home that had
her body
he said that he was a friend of her
families
and said could I take a picture of the
body
as a Keepsake for the parents
this rocker body yes
oh they probably went hell no and they
yeah they basically said [__] no you
can't do that yeah and he said according
to the funeral director
he said you mean you can't fix her up
enough so I could just get one picture
of her he said
and they were like no you're not [__]
doing that
and then they called the family and
they're like you know they're like do
you know a guy that looks like this and
they described you know spoiler alert it
was [__] him yeah I mean the way that
he described him it's like it had to be
him
and they were like yeah we don't know
that I don't know and she was just
rotten as hell unless I hadn't seen a
long time I mean
maybe he did maybe he moved it while it
was still fresh he hadn't seen it in a
long time maybe he wanted to see how
rotten it was
yeah this dude he wanted to make because
he can't be that dumb he wanted to know
if the [__] was presentable Maybe
maybe he was afraid of forensics at the
time you want to know how wrong she was
maybe he felt that he left with some
evidence behind yeah maybe he was just
trying to like see if he was going to
get busted or he could have had some
weird like fetish or something he would
have probably you know I think I think
he's trying to confirm to himself that
it's too rotten to be shown
Maybe
yeah there's someone in ulterior motive
there yeah well I'm probably worried
about it yeah this was his first one
yeah probably afraid of getting caught
he's probably wondering you know if they
saw that I did this and this and that to
her they might know it's me
but then
he's like yeah but she might be so
rotten they can't tell well how do I
know well let's go go ask to see if
they'll show it to you they won't show
it to you they know he can't be that
[__] bright because it's like well
anybody in their right mind would know
that that [__] [__] was suspicious
like coming to the funeral home hey can
I take a picture of it and the weird
thing about it is that he didn't even
have a camera like the the lady at the
reception was like he didn't have a
camera with him so he must
that's weird
he's not dumb he's scared
and acting dumb remember he's probably
about like [__] Charles or back to
China
it's probably like Dennis
oh it's probably like Raider remember
Dennis [__] thought that he could
trust the cops
yeah something like that like he's not
he's like this is okay so this maybe
specifically is I invented a word the
other day like I invented it actually
for myself but it could apply in this
situation as well
um smart-hearted you're smart Jenny is
smart-hearted
yeah well that's what I said I said I
came up with like I use that to describe
myself because I'm like I'm really smart
but I'm also like really kind of stupid
yeah
or something well honestly like probably
if I went to if I went to somebody to
get it diagnosed I'm sure I would come
out on the Spectrum somewhere I'm sure
but it's like you know I never did but I
suspect
but yeah but I think this is like
another aspect of a smart-heartedness
where and like you said Dennis kind of
had that thing too where it's like he
seemed like he you know obviously he
wasn't stupid or he would have gotten
caught like immediately and he didn't
get caught for like 30 years but then
like just real dumb [__] yeah he would
fall for real dumb [__] Dennis when he
killed Nancy Fox he went to the pay
phone and called the crime in to 9-1-1
he's he said that that kept him awake
for a long [__] time he couldn't get
any sleep because he he was like how
they hear my they heard my voice and
they played it on the news how could
they not know that that was me right
yeah I said somebody's going to hear
that who knows me he's going to say yeah
that's that's that that's Dennis Rader
and when you hear the the recording it's
[__] Dennis Raider you could easily
tell the damn voice easily he has a
pretty distinct yes I mean you know you
can tell exactly that Tom knows
[__] and I guess [__] that's
[__] Raider and uh it's a miracle
that
people that knew him did not recognize
his voice that voice I guess you
wouldn't think about it like out of
context because it's just kind of like I
kind of think to myself what if I saw
the news you know or something and like
somebody was like hey this is somebody
we think is a serial killer and then it
was somebody's voice that I recognized I
don't know if I would necessarily make
that connection I mean unless it was
real distinctive like what if it like if
it was your voice or something maybe I
wouldn't recognize it but it's just like
well I'm saying [__] Dennis had
relatives that heard that [__] right I
think you'd think they would have to
have heard that they'd be like hey
that's okay but then they were like well
he wouldn't do that I couldn't be him
people that worked with him and
everything but uh Dennis said he did
that [__] just on a whim called him
weird just on a whim day he didn't think
anything out about it until after I mean
I don't think on the news and he was
[__] petrified
it might have been what did he think was
going to happen might have been what
happened this must have been the first
victim
and he was amazed that the body wasn't
found he kept going and checking on it
yeah I I suspect because this was they
think this was his first one right so
yeah maybe this might have been he was
like that's six he might have been
checking on it at first yeah I can't
believe they haven't found this right
you know it's still there and uh
then he worried about it when they did
find it he wanted to know what the
status was maybe he hadn't seen it for a
while
and was afraid that they'd be able to
somehow link that body to him
and he thought the litmus test was well
they won't show it to me or take a
picture of it then I'll know that's
rotten Tammy said maybe he wanted a
picture to jack off to
um possibly maybe I mean like I said I I
wouldn't doubt it like with some of the
later [__] to happen but you know I
don't know I don't think so it was
something more basic than that it has
something to do with getting caught let
me go to the restaurant maybe yeah maybe
because this was the first getting
caught he's afraid he's getting caught
Juan says Jenny is beautiful
thank you thank you very much yeah James
says way too many people have similar
voices you brush it off as someone who
just sounds like them yeah especially if
it was somebody you knew like I said if
I heard somebody they said oh my God we
think this [__] is a serial
killer and they played a voice and it
sounded like Tom's voice I'd be like
that can't be tough you know although
Tom has a pretty sick voice I'm gonna
say but I wouldn't think that he was a
serial killer you know what I mean he's
just not that type of dude but I don't
know they say that about our lives I
don't know they probably said that about
Dennis too it's like oh that can't be
done and that's here's the thing too
this [__] John Norman Collins
um as far as I know like like I said
he's still alive and he's in prison his
family and friends and [__] like that
they are adamant that he is not the
killer that he was railroaded
um that all of the people that
identified in bloody blah were like
mistaken it was like some other dude
some other kind of [__] and they will
just not have it and they still like go
visit him and everything like his mom
does and I don't know if his mom does
anymore because she might have passed
away by now but you know the the stuff I
was reading in like the documentary of
the stuff they said that she was just
adamant that that was that was her baby
and he just didn't do any of that [__]
despite all the evidence to the contrary
um and he never confessed to it either
but I don't know I'm just you know I
wasn't there but I'm 99 sure that this
[__]
did all the [__] that they think that he
did but yeah so so we asked if he could
take a picture of the body and they said
absolutely not what the [__] are you
even thinking of
um so the the receptionist that that
worked at the funeral home
she said she's like she didn't get a
super good look at him like or you know
think that much about it but she said
you know he's like a white dude like
looked kind of athletic kind of handsome
um had dark hair like real clean cut
looking and she also said that he had
driven a bluish gray Chevy which if
you'll remember is the same car that uh
Mary Fletcher's neighbor had seen kind
of going alongside her like before she
disappeared
so there's that
now about a year later uh this was also
in July but in 1968
another body was found this young woman
was 20 years old again she was very
decomposed and had been horribly
mutilated
she was an art student named Joan shell
and she was found alongside of a road in
Ann Arbor
she had been raped uh stabbed 25 times
uh with a four inch knife
um and all of these like all the wounds
like they punctured her liver her lungs
and her carotid artery
one of the wounds
had been apparently the killer had
stabbed her like behind her left ear and
stabbed her so hard that it broke her
skull
he had also slashed her throat
and then taken her mini skirt and pulled
it up and tied it around her neck
now something interesting about this
particular body and they kind of went
into this a lot like in the book that I
read about this which like I said it's
on Kindle unlimited for free if you want
to read it it's just called the Michigan
murders it came out in the 70s but it's
it has like a lot of details about the
stuff
um so she had been dead for several days
they were sure
but the top half of her body
like her head and you know this the top
half of her torso was really decomposed
they're like it was just black and just
covered with maggots and everything like
that but the lower half of her body like
her legs and stuff was a lot more
preserved
so they thought what had happened was
that her body had been kept somewhere
for several days where like maybe part
of her body was like in a shadow and
then this part was like in a Sunbeam
they seemed like it kind of seemed like
that so like it was in a building
somewhere where there was obviously like
a large temperature differential because
there was a huge difference in the
decomposition and they thought that was
really strange
now because there was no I've been in
water uh no they they found out where it
was later on yeah and they and they
figured it out okay but um but they just
thought it was weird at the time because
they weren't really sure they knew that
she had not been killed there because
there wasn't any uh blood around the
corpse or anything like that
um and also nobody had this was this was
an area like I said it was it wasn't
hidden it was like kind of on the side
of a road and nobody had noticed the
body up until recently so thank you very
much Ian England happy no more [__]
tourist week guys yeah
Tammy said uh I went to school with a
girl whose last name was boob oh [__]
I knew a girl in school whose last name
was butts poor little girl she got me
and her mom's name was lovely
and I was like gosh that's awful yeah
her mom's name is lovely butts I can't
remember what the little girl's name was
yeah somebody needs to [__] change
their last name that's terrible
yeah I would totally change my mind and
my first name but that's a [__] porn
name of course it is the stripper name
yeah and it's like nobody would think
that was a real name but it's like yeah
I really knew a Nerf person named that
sad but yeah so um so they thought that
the body had been dumped here recently
like it had been capped somewhere else
for several days and then was dumped
here perhaps to you know make it easier
for people to find
um he did kind of try to hide it a
little bit by putting like some grass
and [__] over it but you know it was
pretty easy to see anyway
so
um they pretty much even though this is
the late 60s this is a 1968.
um so they didn't the term serial killer
was not in use uh I don't believe that
was in common use until the 1970s at
least I think before that they did use
I had seen um like a murder series or
something but nobody really said serial
killer like until the 70s like they knew
that [__] existed but they didn't really
have a thing about it like they have now
but they did
um from the beginning like know that
these two crimes were probably related
because of the similarity in the uh the
wounds and stuff
so at this point they're like okay we're
gonna have like a little like four Dudes
like four detectives who are gonna work
on this just these two murders like full
time because we're pretty sure that's
the same dude doing this
now they found out later that Joan shell
uh had last been seen by her roommate
whose name was Susan Colby at a bus stop
and this was on uh June 30th 1968. now
what Joan was gonna do was she was going
to go to Ann Arbor to see her boyfriend
and her roommate walked her to the bus
stop
however
um she had apparently missed the last
bus so she told her roommate Susan oh
I'm just gonna hitchhike at which point
Susan's like I don't know if that's like
a good idea
and she said while she was standing
there a car pulled up she said it was a
red and black like a two-tone Pontiac
Bonneville and there were three
white men in it like young white dudes
like that look like college students
and so the car slowed down and the
driver asked if she wanted a ride and
Joan got in the car now the driver of
this car they're pretty sure was Collins
because the description that she gave of
him like fitted his description so they
think that he was and like I said they
found out who the other two dudes were
later on and that this was probably him
but he was in a different car than he
had been the first time because it was
some I think it was someone else's car
his roommate's car or something like
that or his friend
but yeah so there's three dudes in the
car and they picked her up and she
subsequently disappeared so like I said
now her roommate had basically said look
I said please do not get in this car
which you know would have been the wise
course of action but um Jones like no I
really wanted to get to Ann Arbor I
wanted to see my boyfriends it's like
these dudes seem fine so um yeah so
she's like well as soon as you get there
call me so I know that you got there
okay
but of course she didn't call
um so so she was the one that uh Susan
rather was the one that called the
police and she it was only like three
hours later because she's like look she
would have called me and something is
terribly wrong yeah yeah so um she's
like she should have been there ages ago
and she never showed up so she was the
one that actually reported her missing
so they go through like all of these red
and black cars they go through all of
these Alibis you know of people that
looked like that dude and everything
like that but they couldn't really get
anywhere with it they ran out of leads
so essentially this is I guess like in
hindsight it's just kind of like this is
kind of [__] up but really like by the
time like a month and a half had gone by
like six weeks or something like that
they're like well we um have exhausted
all of our leads so
sorry like we're at a loss pretty much
uh and they didn't even I think they
took two of the detectives off the off
the [__] because they just didn't have
anything else to look into I guess now
they did have a big reward
I think at the time it was 7 800 for
um you know I think in 1968 money which
I'm not sure what that is nowadays but
um you know leading to information and
stuff like that but apparently like it
didn't really go anywhere
now they also said like a couple months
after the murder
um they had two eyewitnesses who were
also like college students in the area
and they came forward and told police
they're like well we're not real sure
about this and it's like we're kind of
like reluctant to say this because we
don't want to get anybody into trouble
but they're like we're pretty sure that
we saw Joan shell walking with a dude on
Emmett Street on the same night that she
disappeared and we're pretty sure that
this guy was John Norman Collins because
they knew him yeah they're like we're
not absolutely sure and like I said we
don't want to get him into trouble maybe
it wasn't him we weren't entirely sure
but we think that's who it was it was
like a guy and his girlfriend
um yeah so they said yeah he was this
guy he went to um Eastern Michigan
University he was uh he wanted to become
a teacher which is terrible but yeah so
he was his major was elementary
education and he actually lived right
across the street from Joan shell matter
of fact uh he had an apartment like in a
building right across from her and uh
like I said he looked very much like the
person that uh the roommate had
described as picking her up like driving
that car
now they did bring Collins in
and you know they questioned him now he
said I don't even know her
um I wasn't even here that weekend I was
uh you know in Centerline which is uh
outside of Detroit that's where his mom
lives that's where he was from
originally it's like I was there over
the weekend visiting them and it's like
I didn't even get back here until like
after she had disappeared or whatever
now because like I said he seemed
not like a weirdo he seemed just to look
like a kind of clean-cut dude like a
college student or anything they didn't
the cops didn't really follow up on it
there was kind of a lot of I felt kind
of bad for some of the cops because
um some of the [__] that happened was
probably not their fault or [__] that
they had to do or whatever but it's just
like the media were really really hard
on them which like I said you can see
why because as the murderers started
piling up like everyone was freaking out
you know what I mean it's like who the
[__] is doing this and why can't you
catch them so and a couple of things
that happened like later on you know
they they would call them Keystone Cops
and [__] like that like in the [__] I
mean is that because I saw some of the
original like newspaper stuff but yeah
um so in hindsight like I said not great
they did bring him in for questioning
but he was just like yeah I don't even
know her and I wasn't even here so when
they didn't even check so you know what
I mean so that was that
so then
um it was a little while before there
was another one
March 20th 1969. uh and this one I'm
gonna say right now they're pretty sure
that this might have been somebody else
well but there was like enough
similarity that they kind of like
thought they were linked at the
beginning
but this woman she was 23 and she was um
went to the University of Michigan now
she was a law student she was a little
bit older
um than most of the other uh you know
most of the other victims
her name is Jane mixer now what happened
with her was she was um you know how
like at colleges they have those
bulletin boards where it's like you have
a ride boards like I need to ride here
there or the other place and like you
get people to like hook up on that like
they used to so she had needed a ride to
uh Muskegon which was her hometown
and she was going to go there to tell
her family that she had gotten engaged
and she was going to move to New York
City after she graduated
so she apparently had found somebody to
give her a ride
but then she disappeared
now they found her the next morning dead
however she was fully clothed
um she had like a raincoat over her
and uh she was actually found in a
cemetery like laying on top of a grave
in Denton Cemetery which is in Van Buren
Township
now when they did the autopsy she had
actually been shot in the head twice
with a 22 caliber pistol then um the the
person had like tied a nylon stocking
around her neck a nylon stocking which
um according to the size was not hers so
they thought that was a little bit weird
um she had also not been raped and had
not been murdered at the site where her
body was found as she was killed
somewhere else and dumped there
now because she had not been raped they
did note that her tights had been kind
of like pulled down
and she had she was on her period also
because they said she had like a well it
wouldn't have been a maxi pad back then
because I don't think they had those so
I guess it would have just been one of
those napkin deals
um so they thought that maybe there was
a sexual motive even though like I said
she had not been raped
um but she hadn't been mutilated or
beaten or stabbed or anything like that
but the fact that she was a student from
that area the fact that she'd had like a
stocking tied around her neck and the
fact that she was you know in the same
area where a lot of these murders had
taken place they were like well we're
not sure if this is the same perp but
there's enough similarities to maybe
like tentatively link them at this time
so that's what they did oh that was him
um actually no it wasn't uh it turned
out later on that it wasn't okay but um
because they did DNA but we'll get into
that a little bit later but yeah they
figured he pulled it down for the
thought that she was looking on her
period he's like oh [__] her they just
shower well no because yeah well yeah
we'll get into that a little bit because
most of the victims actually were on
their periods that's why people thought
that it was this same like not all of
them but most of them how would he know
well I'll get into that too okay
I'll get into that too baby he found out
that they were he goes into a rage he
dirty horse I think that that is more
yeah along the lines of what it probably
was because we'll we'll get into that
later like after they caught him and
they talked to like some of his uh
girlfriends okay yeah like we'll get
into that
now four days
after they found Jane mixer's body they
found another body
this one was found nude and mutilated
and this was a teenage girl
now this was found like kind of line
lying on top of this jacket behind an
abandoned house
now the body was found it wasn't far
from where Joan shell had been found and
that had been eight months before
um now they said they're pretty sure
again this is the same perp uh but the
torture and the wounds and stuff like
that were way worse so they said
somebody is escalating you know what I
mean this particular girl how old was
she again uh I believe she was 16. damn
well oh they got younger than that okay
um yeah she was 16 years old
um actually some of the investigators
that like saw the body they said this is
like we've been on the forest for like
30 years and this is the worst [__]
we've ever seen yeah
um so her cause of death was a fractured
skull numerous fractures to the skull
feed around the head to the killer uh
yeah they said one third of her of her
skull was pretty much just crushed yeah
um and it was a heavy blunt instrument
they don't know what the instrument was
uh who knows baseball bat could have
been anything something like that
um so yeah so she had basically been
tortured
um the killer just come on it was
Collins
um he took off her shirt and stuffed it
down into her throat into her trachea
uh apparently to keep her from screaming
um while he beat her about the head and
upper body
um that alone would have killed her
though wouldn't it well yeah we'll get
into that
um but yeah he also had a what they
think was a leather strap and just beat
the [__] out of her with that
um around yeah
um and they think that she was
restrained while he just like went at
her with with that
um all around like her legs and
everything like that and then as if that
wasn't bad enough he went to a nearby
tree
broke off a branch
and stuck it up her vagina eight inches
um now we don't know the order though do
we well the girl they are pretty sure
that she was alive for most of that
because
um this in this case uh the just the way
that there was um you know the
disturbance in the soil and stuff like
that looked like she had struggled well
she's flopping around my right like
while so away from the blows right
tied her up yeah
um
strip her clothes off
hit her with a belt
stop something stuff something about
better at some time that might have been
the last thing he did sometimes
sometimes they do that
try to humiliate him after death not too
yeah that's pretty professional you know
we just did a few minutes after she's
probably already dead when he did that
well that's what and actually when I was
reading the book like the cops and
everything were like they they prayed
that she was already dead when that
happened yeah it was probably after
death he's probably sitting there
looking at her and then did that
I mean it's not like well she was alive
during all the beating and [__] like
that so it's like I'm not saying that
was [__] yeah a lot of that was
probably with the Bell
and then uh he pulled that shirt off of
her stuffed it down her throat and she
was [__] choking out he [__]
finished her off with heavy blows to the
head with something
some kind of object he had
and like I said I don't I don't think
they ever determined what it was yeah
I'm assuming it was something like a
back or
ax handle or something like that maybe
there was a big
log like a big [__] tree limb or
something
but a lot of times those are light
there's probably something heavy some
from his car
it's amazing yeah because they said like
most of her skull was just crushed yeah
you know yeah that's how he killed her
yeah
um
she all that rolling around was probably
to get away from that belt yeah that's
what they think because it's belt off it
started because they think that she was
restrained yeah that he had like tied
her up and then was like when she was
laying on the ground and just like
beating the [__] out of her and she was
trying to get away obviously she would
yeah yeah okay so they eventually
identified this victim as again a 16
year old high school girl
his name is Marilyn Skelton uh she had
last been seen outside of a restaurant
on uh Washtenaw Avenue
um but she they think she disappeared
while she was hitchhiking but she had
last been seen two days before her body
was discovered some little chick he
picked up
yeah and um she probably went willingly
with it
well that's what I mean I think a lot of
um the victims did and like I said I'm
not victim blaming or anything like that
because hitchhiking was very common back
then and
I mean nine times out of ten it seemed
like most people got to their
destinations obviously because I've
known people that grew up in that time
period like yeah we didn't think about
it we just hitchhiked all the time I'm
like you are a crazy person but it's
like but most of the time they didn't
get murdered but he's in his 20s at this
time he's a good looking guy he's in his
20s at this time isn't he yeah like
early 20s yeah I think he was 21 yeah
she would have saw him as a catch
they were probably making out
maybe they decide to kill her for some
reason yeah
because that's what he was into yeah
yeah
it's [__] up dude's a dick
uh yeah
oh you know [__] you know something
something set him off
something triggers this [__]
homicidal rage in him he's got some kind
of fetish for it
for some reason
he's hoping that they'll trigger it
that's what I'm thinking yeah it did
yeah it's not like that it just happens
to him right no he wants it to happen
yeah
yeah I think he's got to find a reason
to let loose on her yeah because he
knows that nobody knows that they're
together
yeah because there's nothing to connect
them
but yeah so obviously um they're
thinking this is the same perpetrator um
you know very very similar uh Mo they
found um a garter belt I don't know if
it belonged to her or not but um it had
been tied around her neck also and
another thing that he would do pretty
commonly was um kind of take all their
clothes and like fold them their clothes
and shoes and like put them next to the
body now he did take some of the shoes
because some of the bodies they just
found that just had like one shoe there
or they didn't find so he did take
trophies but we'll get into that we'll
do it later too so you must had a foot
finish yeah I think the first victim was
the only one that that happened to like
where he cut the feet off but like I
said that was his first one maybe he
lost the shoes so he says I'm gonna take
the feet instead yeah who knows I don't
know I I don't know I'm not a serial
killer so I don't know what their
thought processes are you know what I
mean but yeah
um now interestingly at first okay so
there were kind of two schools that
thought with this particular murder
because um you know most of the more
seasoned investigators I feel were like
like um you're pretty sure 99 sure this
is the same perpetrator because
obviously like I said the ammo was very
similar however
because uh Marilyn was
um actually a known drug dealer and
actually like a drug user and she was
like a little bit of a runaway and stuff
like that she was also a police
informant so there was a small
contingent in the um of investigators
usually like the younger guys that
thought oh well maybe this was drug
related
um but the older guys were like yeah but
she wasn't a high enough up in like drug
dealing or enough of a police informant
to have that done to her it's like it
really doesn't seem like
you know I mean yeah sometimes like if
you [__] over like a dealer or something
like that yeah they'll do [__] up [__]
to you but not usually like roll sexual
[__] like this so most of the people
were like yeah we're pretty sure this is
like the same guy but there was like a
small contingent that thought maybe it
was drug related but you know that was
kind of like a minority I feel like
so at this point um even though they
didn't use the term serial killer yet uh
they were pretty sure that that was what
they had on their hands even though they
didn't call it that so they essentially
put together a like a task force where
they brought because some of the bodies
were found like in different uh
jurisdictions I believe at this point it
was five different jurisdictions so um
you know because wherever the victims
were taken from and wherever the bodies
were found were sometimes in different
jurisdictions so they kind of had to
like get everybody together and have a
task force like share information and
[__] like that so it took them that long
to do that this was March 24th of I
believe 1969 like after this particular
murder
so um so at this point they know that
almost all of the victims were brunettes
uh you know they're all they were all
white
um other than Jane mixer
um they had been uh killed with uh you
know a blunt instrument or stabbing uh
that too
they had all been found uh within a 15
mile radius of Washington County
damn and other than Jane mixer uh again
who like I said spoiler alert later on
they found out someone else had killed
her but um everybody else was probably
this [__] uh they all had knife
wounds in their neck
um all of them also had an item of
clothing of some description tied around
their neck um all of them had that and
almost all of them either all of them or
almost all of them had been on their
period
um there was also rumors going around
too that they all had dangly earrings on
but I think only five of them did like
out of all of them because like I said
many were there total
um they think there were seven okay five
uh six of them in Michigan and one in
California
no no no no no this isn't yeah okay this
isn't we're not to the end yeah we're
like on motor three or four I think yeah
I think this was the fourth one yeah but
and like I said and one of the ones that
I talked about was they found out later
than it was that it wasn't him
because of DNA but they didn't find that
out until like many years later
so yeah um
so so yeah like I said it's weird
because I think like on the notes and
some of the um other uh you know
write-ups that I read about this they
said all of them were on their period
but I think in the book I think he said
the majority of them were on their
period but I'm not sure if all of them
were but it was kind of like significant
enough that
we'll get into that a little bit later
because he seemed to have like a
particular disgust for menstruation and
it might have been a case where he tried
to get busy with the chick and she was
on her period And he was like ooh gross
I'm gonna kill this one like I kind of
feel like that might have been effective
yeah right so that means he's cruising
around he's picking up lots of girls
because he's good looking
yeah if they're not if they're if
they're not on the rag they get they
they live they get away with it
if they are then he gets mad it's like
he's been denied
yeah like we can help it or yeah how
dare you yeah we'll just wait stop it
why'd you let me yeah
yeah something like that I remember did
I tell you that one time where I saw
like this dude talking about
somebody's talking about periods or
something like that and he's like just
hold it and I was like
you don't know how periods work too he
thinks he thinks this I think he could
just hold it like pee yeah yeah okay
that's not how that works
that's awesome though and I was just
like I was like for a second I was like
please tell me that dude is joking but I
I gotta be joking I feel like maybe not
though well no because well the thing
about it is I think a lot of them could
have been a kid that's what I mean like
younger dudes I don't think they really
teach it or they're grossed out by it
and they don't want to hear about it so
it's just kind of like I I can see like
a dude legit thinking that yeah like
that like that you could just hold it
doesn't really know about the vaginal
wall and all that you don't know what's
[__] breaking down and coming out I'm
like oh I wish I could hold it he
doesn't know about the cervix and [__]
but it doesn't know thankfully I don't
have to go through that [__]
I think I'm old now yeah that sucks
doesn't know Anatomy he doesn't guess
the Fallopian tubes and all that yeah
white people said just suspend gravity
yeah pretty much that's what they're
asking you to do well you can just
tighten it up and hold it yeah I was
like yeah that's probably what he says
uh that works that's probably they do is
probably as well that works I hope so I
I hope that that wasn't like a 20 odd
year old they would just hold it what
are you talking I know I'm like yeah
don't you think we would [__] do that
do you have any idea like how [__] up
that is to deal with every [__] four
weeks of your life for years and decades
and decades I'm like it sucks
like if we had some way to just [__]
stop it we would yeah you know what I
mean man Bros are funny they are very
funny
yeah white people says cork yeah but you
kind of do they just [__] stuff a rag
up well that's what I mean that's what I
was gonna say you are kind of quirking
it up yeah cork won't work you got to do
cotton that was the old way they'd do it
stuff something up in there
well it's not the old way they still do
anything yeah they just they have
products made for it yeah but now they
have more than before the products yeah
you just have to say yeah
what you know what else could you do
yeah I could do that otherwise it's just
gonna [__] go in yeah you know what I
mean it will it'll just go everywhere
but uh yeah we've all had that happen
well pretty much every girl has had that
happen but it's disgusting but yeah
it's not fun it's not fun
okay so the next victim was found on
April 16th 1969.
in the morning and this one was the
youngest one she was 13 years old
uh her name was Dawn basem
now they found her uh alongside a Road
in Ypsilanti all she was wearing was uh
she had like a white blouse and a bra on
but they've been pushed up around her
neck he's going younger and younger yeah
he's seeing what he can get away with
I guess so yeah and he might be kind of
like scrape from his point of view
scraping the bottom of the barrel
it might be that the older ones are not
[__] dumb enough to get in the car
with him at this point or he's [__]
afraid you know
maybe he doesn't have the confidence he
had it could be that yeah possibly he's
going out for an easier victim yeah it
might be easier probably not harder it's
probably physically easier well he's
probably she's probably like half his
[__] size or smaller guys she's only
13. she's kind of dumb you know I mean I
don't have any experience and you know
he probably flirts with her and she gets
in the car with him
yeah maybe oh he's a good looking guy
you know like I said 20. people didn't
really um think about it all that much
like especially in the late 60s and
early 70s like people just hitchhiked
and they didn't really think that much
about it yeah I guess they were a lot
more trusting back then yeah
let's see that we'll see what that gets
here
Michael said I once dated a girl and she
never talked about her period and it
seemed every night was available for sex
well she might have been on the pill
ow
um if you I don't know if you know this
but when they give you a birth control
pill they give you like it's supposed to
be three weeks of the pill and then it's
like a week of
uh Placebo so that you you have your
period but you don't have to take those
Placebo ones you can just go and take
all this it won't hurt you or nothing
like that but it just keeps you remember
like a lot of girls do that yeah and you
know look a few women out there I'm
gonna give some advice about the pill
and you say how's this [__]
going to give women the advice about the
pill because I've [__] with all kinds
of [__] synthetic hormones
some [__] that produces progesterone and
all kinds of stuff my HRT is kind of
like the male equivalent of being on the
pill it'll shut down your fertility if
you don't take an antidote for it it's
called HCG or Clomid all right which is
an antidote for
know what I know personally
about [__] with your hormones if I
was a young woman today I would not go
on that pill
the long-term effects of having a an
imbalance like that especially if it's a
progesteronic imbalance it will
seriously affect your life it'll it'll
affect the type of men you're attracted
to that's how far it goes some people
like well how could that [__] be when
I was on tread just loaded full of
[__] progesterone
Jenny will tell you stories about what I
thought was okay yeah yeah like I think
I'm gonna cut this guy's head off you
know I mean that's yeah just casual
casualism
let's not do that let's not yeah because
you're just let's dial it back yes just
a tad you become Superman all right
you're hyper masculine on one end but
the progesterone level's so high no man
should have that much progesterone in
them you're pregnant Superman you're
[__] you're Superman on PMS all right
or some [__] like that and you just get
simpy as [__] and it and [__] I've
been hearing testimony from women what
long term
pill usages like and I know exactly what
they're talking about you shouldn't take
that long term it'll [__] up your
development
well I would not take the pill at all if
I was a woman I would use condoms
just wouldn't use it at all don't [__]
with your hormones like that
and unless you try to get jacked and
they got fitness women well the thing
about it well like like I said
everybody's different I I was on the
pill for a very long time like in my 20s
and 30s and I didn't have any side
effects or anything like that and it was
completely effective well you don't know
um no no I'm just saying that not that I
noticed you know what I mean yeah
because then I was if you weren't on it
and then I was off them yeah for a while
and then I went back on them and when I
went back on them they turned me into a
fat crazy person yeah but that had I had
never had that happen like when I was
younger another thing too because
Michael said um uh wow I should have
known this yeah but like a lot of girls
do that I didn't do that
um but a lot of girls did do that where
they just take the three weeks of the
pill and then just skip the placebo and
they just so they don't have their
period because having your period sucks
but I will note and maybe maybe this is
gross or TMI or whatever but there's
also if you get like something like a
diva cup or something like that where
it's just like this big huge cup and you
just stick it up like up in your cervix
or whatever and you can still have sex
with those like and it won't get
everywhere yeah because I used those
before and they actually work pretty
good I would not if
man can [__] with his hormones the older
he gets the more he can [__] with his
hormones
he's already had kids he doesn't have to
worry about it uh you're after 35 your
test levels are starting to plummet
anyway you can supplement them by
putting more tests in there and [__]
doing other [__] exotic [__] [__]
you put that in there you'll start to
kind of grow younger if you [__] do
get the doses right
you don't want to do that to a 16 year
old boy or an 18 year old boy in high
school that's where all these horror
stories he's got a good endocrine system
he doesn't need that
older people can [__] with hormones
younger people let it run its course
with these women
I'd never put them on a pill they're
putting these pills the girls on a pill
at 14. that's [__] insane
well now there are other uses for it
it's not just birth control um so it's
good for like endometriosis and things
like that too which which is when I knew
some younger girls that were put on it
was mostly for that
um but like I said everybody's different
they do kind of have those um now I
haven't [__] with any of these but
they do have different stuff where they
like inject the [__] in your arm and
it's good for like five years or they
have that copper IUD thing like some
people like that although some people
don't really like it because it's like
really painful I would use
I would yeah if I was younger now I
would probably use that because you
don't know how that if hormones affect
the development of the it affects the
mind and if you're taking them young
they affect the development of the
person
if your foot here here are the basic
symptoms
not a pill with a woman fat crazy
attracted to betas
that's a loss of [__]
um loss of Gusto and enjoyment of Life
loss of ambition
um
a loss of [__] empathy that's another
thing that it does to women they become
less empathetic towards other people uh
they don't have the kind of the reaction
towards seeing children as strongly as
they would women involved females of all
species evolve to be the way they are
you shouldn't really [__] with the
hormones now maybe after the age of 35
or maybe if you want to shut it down
because your your personality is fixed
by then
and you've had normal hormones sex drive
usually goes away
and um no I wouldn't if I was a woman
know what I would know now I would if I
was a woman I'd [__]
know what I know if I was a woman a
young woman I'd never take that well I
would probably like I said if I was
young nowadays I would probably go with
the IUD although I've heard some people
like I have like a lot of pain with
those but mostly I've heard like good
[__] about that but I didn't really I
didn't do that back then because it was
just easier and I took them for many
years like without anything am I advice
to all the men and the women out of
there don't go on gear or [__] eat
hormone replacement until you're at
least 35 don't [__] with any issue under
35 be natural
trained naturally
unless you're professional unless you're
a professional athlete they have the
discipline the training to [__] once
you go on you're on for the rest of your
life
you got to be disciplined and have the
money and know how to [__] take care
of your health just like these girls
these [__] girls getting titty
implants big breast implants at 20.
they're in there for life
and you're now in the breast game they
only last about 15 20 years and you got
to keep replacing them but that's the
commitment these porn star girls makes
or these girls that want if you have an
A cup and you want a [__] a double eat
cup you're gonna have to put implants in
there but that's a commitment
now you're in the implant game hormones
are the same way well it's a body
modification it's a body mod as soon as
you start injecting hormones you've got
to be on your game for it for the rest
of your life
you can kind of come off if you're a guy
young guy but uh you probably won't
chances are you're gonna be on there
because you don't want to go back to
normal
yeah Ian said all the girls I know that
run the pill non-stop have terrible
facial acne and terrible mental health
yeah like I said I took a I took it for
many years and didn't have any uh issues
their body composition goes to hell too
well no I'm just saying when I was in my
20s and 30s I was on it and it's like I
didn't have any weight gain I didn't
have like bad you know acne or anything
like that but when I went off them for
many years and then went back on them
then I started having problems like with
weight gain and acting crazy and stuff
but whenever yeah I was on it for
15 20 years something like that like in
my 20s and 30s and didn't have any side
effects at all same can be said with
[__] testosterone and the other [__]
they don't and steroids they don't
affect everybody the same way you
actually have to try it
to know what happened yeah everybody's
different everybody's a little bit
different like I said and age is a huge
Factor age and even if it's the same
person it's like I said because I took
birth control pills with no issues right
for for decades and then I went off them
for a while and then when when I went
back on them then I started having
issues but I hadn't had issues before
that well that's why I wasn't worried
about taking them later because I had
taken them a lot before and where it
happens to birth control
the eggs
to stay in storage
okay so the period's getting rid of
those eggs
well the eggs are just in storage while
you're shut down and then when you start
it back up to have a kid who knows the
reliability and the quality of those
eggs they haven't been
being thrown not being flushed out
they're not well it's not just the egg
that's flushed out it's all of the
uterine lining and oh yeah that kind of
stuff you have to flush all that [__]
out you know how does that affect
children that you have later
it's unknown because you don't know what
could have been you only deal with what
you get let's say you compared you had
different universes and you appear the
kid you would have had without the
[__] pill and the kids you did have
with the bill later they might have been
very different kids yeah but it's like
there's no way of knowing no way no it's
like you could go crazy like thinking
about it natural it's best to stay
natural I mean like mostly I'm just kind
of like yeah I mean you know barring
having some kind of like horrible
disease or like some kind of thing that
necessitates that it's like it's
probably just best to let it ride just
not take as much stuff as like I said if
I was you know younger nowadays I would
probably go the IUD route to be honest
but instead of the pill but I didn't I
didn't have any issues with the pillow
at least at first but then like later on
when I started taking them again in my
mid to late 30s then I started having
problems like with weight gain and
mental problems and [__] like that but I
took them for a long time without ever
having any problems
so you know
um yeah Sebastian said the mother of my
son when I first met her was on the pill
would have mega rages yeah I just put it
down to her Viking ancestry yeah I mean
I was never that bad
um you know what I mean I'm pretty
low-key and I have like a pretty
you know I don't get in these big like
[__] ragey kind of things or see I'm
pretty like even keeled but
even that I didn't really like love it
you know nothing like nothing like Tom
on Trend that was like
like I said
that was like a hundred times worse than
anything I would have experienced on the
bill so you know what I mean like that
was way [__] out there I never acted
that bad like when I was on that [__] I
never wanted to be like I'm just gonna
cut some motherfucker's head off and
like just
starting random fights which is people
that glanced at you funny or something
like that you know what I mean because
he was just insane but yeah I didn't
have anything that bad
but yeah so where was I okay so let's
get back to the case so yeah this victim
here 13 years old
so um so not only had her like the only
clothing that they found you know on the
body still was like her little blouse
and her little bra and that had been
pushed up around her neck
um she had also been stabbed multiple
times
in her chest uh also had been stabbed in
her vagina
also the killer had uh slashed across
her breasts which I think a lot of the
uh victims had
um and across her butt and across her
stomach like he just like slashed her
all over
and then um he strangled her with like a
like an electrical cord like to feed him
electrical cord like a black one I think
uh they also found a handkerchief
stuffed into her throat again just like
the previous victim
um and in this case this is why I kind
of think that maybe he was moving the
[__] around is because he left this girl
her body in a place where you couldn't
miss it
like he wanted her to be found yeah you
know what I mean like he left her like
right on the side of a road
so she was found like pretty quickly
afterward
um they did not think she was raped
though but again you know it's clearly a
sexual motive even if there's no actual
rape involved yeah
so yeah so she was basically found the
next day because she had been seen alive
the night before like at 7 30.
um she was actually walking she was at
her friend's house and she was walking
back to her house which was like less
than a mile it was like less than a mile
and actually part of the way
um a friend of hers a guy named Earl was
walking with her and then he's like at
some point we were five blocks from her
house and she would usually take a
shortcut and on a documentary that I saw
they showed like where her actual
because her house is still there
um you know obviously her family does
not live in it anymore but um they
showed where her house was and she would
walk like down this railroad track
because it was a they said you know to
get to the house from where she was if
you had to go like way the [__] around
so it's like most people would just walk
along the railroad track and just kind
of take a shortcut and so that's what
she was doing but they said it was like
five blocks and so at some point
while she was walking those five blocks
like along the shortcut like by the
railroad track she was picked up and she
disappeared
same one yeah yeah she was on foot yeah
she was walking like I said she was
walking from her friend's house like she
usually did like because they lived real
close together yeah he offered her a
ride I guess so
but like I said it was weird because the
way that the because they said the
neighborhood at least when this
documentary came out they said it looked
pretty much the same as it did back then
and it was just like her house was there
there's like the street and then there's
like a there was like a gate of like a
fence and then there was like you know
some you know when they have the um the
railroad track and it's just kind of
like all that gravel or whatever like on
either side and so it was kind of like
that she was just like cutting across
and then cutting over yeah right around
all over the place and I don't see any
13 year old girls just walking around
all right he went out looking for this
he's cruising for these girls yeah I
think he definitely is doing well we'll
find out later that he absolutely was
doing that yeah okay because um
that was kind of his Mo yeah he would go
that's where they'll be because well
later on they found out that like uh
when when they found out it was him like
they would interview people they're like
oh yeah that dude tried to pick me up
like earlier that day you know what I
mean so he was just like cruising
cruising around like trying to get
whoever he could get he didn't Target
anybody in particular he wasn't like
stalking anybody really but well they
did find out later though that Collins
actually did live near to a lot of his
victims so it could be that he was like
had seen them around and so he thought
well because yeah like I'll see them
walking around and they'll might
recognize me because I kind of live
around here too so they wouldn't be
threatened by him so I kind of feel like
there was an aspect of that as well yeah
hunting in his own neighborhood
yeah not the sharpest tool in the shed
but you know
we'll we'll see
so they did actually okay so this was
kind of a big break in the case
because not too long after they found
her body
they found her sweater
in this deserted Farmhouse and it was
only like a hundred yards from the road
where her body was found
and when they looked in this Farmhouse
um you know because they were looking
around all the area and everything like
that so when they found her sweater in
there they said they also found like all
this like kind of broken glass like
little pieces of broken glass and stuff
like that because it you know it was
abandoned Farmhouse it was a bunch of
[__] in there
and they saw that these glass particles
were the same as ones that were on the
bottoms of her shoes
so they started looking around this
Farmhouse and they found another piece
of her clothing
um another piece of that electrical cord
that had been around her neck that they
she had been strangled with and they
found blood stains that looked pretty
Fresh So they were assuming that this
was where she had been killed like so he
had obviously like taken her to this
abandoned Farmhouse and killed her in
there and then dumped her somewhere else
so about a week later like I said
they're kind of crawling all over this
Farmhouse like looking for more uh
evidence and they also found yet another
piece of her clothing and they found an
earring that they later found out
belonged to Marilyn Skelton one of the
other victims in that farmhouse in that
Farmhouse okay so he had scouted this
place out and used it right
so this is all premeditated yeah this is
not this is the place where he killed
probably they think like most of his
early victims yeah other than the one
that had been kind of like um tortured
or like where she where they found her
but other than that I think he took all
of them here at first
and it looked like he had put this stuff
in here
deliberately so they think that maybe he
had killed people and then kept coming
back here like to put stuff here you
know right thanks yeah like the trophies
yeah because they know he kept trophies
we'll find out about that later on too
so at least with these two cases so it's
like okay well the Maryland skeleton
case and the you know the 13 year old
girl it's like so well they know that
those two are for sure links because
obviously this dude brought at least
both of them yeah it was a house or it
was just a barn I think it was just it
was kind of like from way that the way
they described it it kind of sounded
more like a barn okay you know what I
mean but I guess it was kind of big and
the thing about it bedrooms he didn't
have access no I don't think so it
sounded more like a barn type situation
at least from the book that I read they
made it sound more like a barn and it
was and he wasn't here's the thing I
think it must have been like really big
because I don't think he was the only
person that went there I think it was
kind of one of those places where like
you know teenagers and [__] would go to
like hang out and like get high and [__]
because like other people had been there
too but yeah so it couldn't have been
that busy obviously because he wouldn't
have been able to do this crap but yeah
but I think it was a place that like
people that young people in the area
like knew about you know
um now interestingly this is this was
very interesting I found when I read
this in the book Now The Farmhouse or
the barn or whatever actually burned
down
um in what was very clearly an act of
arson
now
um on May the 13th of 1969. now you
would think that the killer had gone
back and burned it down however you
would be mistaken uh the actual arson
had nothing at all to do with the killer
it was just a random [__] that
was mad like I think his girlfriend he'd
taken his girlfriend there like to have
sex and she'd gotten mad and stormed off
and he said you know how to burn this
[__] place down and he burned
it down and yeah I mean he confessed
later on it was him and his a friend of
his
so they'd burn it down so it didn't have
anything to do with you know that being
yeah he wouldn't have burned down his
own [__] uh uh safe space well here's
the creepy [__] though yeah after it
burned down like the cops went out there
to like look at it and they found
five lilacs that had been like clipped
like off of a bush like like a lilac
bush over there laid out on the driveway
and so they were all fresh yeah and so
they thought the killer must because
five victims it had been five victims so
far so like the killer must have come
here and put those there because he
didn't burn the place down like I said
they found the guy that burned the place
down it was just like a random
[__] found out that it burned
down and he went out yeah [__] pay
tribute that's what they think happened
that's what they think happened or to
hit not to his victims but pay tribute
to his prowess of finding his victims
right some weird show
but yeah see I think that's what
happened to you like he went out this he
must have known like that it was well he
was probably going back and forth there
all the time so he probably knew like
right when it burned down yeah which is
[__] up well but he was living at home
huh
no he lived he had an apartment he had
actually lived in a frat house prior to
that because he was in a fraternity but
um yeah we'll get into that later no he
lived in an apartment by um with a
roommate he could
he couldn't it's an apartment so he had
to have another place yeah because I
think he had he had at least one
roommate maybe two I thought he just had
one but yeah he had a roommate
well he was a college student
you know I mean he lived off uh off
campus like in an apartment
Now where's money coming from
um
he I think he had a part-time job okay
he worked in a factory or something I
don't know if he had like I don't know I
don't know if he had a scholarship or if
that and his mom
um like I said he had a single mom and
she
she had a house uh that she had mostly
paid for but she worked as a waitress
but she the weird thing about it is like
after he got caught
like she remortgage the house so she
could pay for a lawyer for him because
she was just dead set that he was
[__] innocent yeah as far as I know
she thought that yeah you know up until
the present day
so
um why people said major oh I guess what
his major was um Elementary education he
wanted to be a teacher
which is pretty scary but yeah that's
what his major was
now about two months later not even two
months later sure he did give a [__]
about his major no I'm sure he didn't no
but that's what that's just what he
that's easy to get that one and that's
what he picked
well the weird thing about it is that
like um apparently like some people that
talk to him like some people that had
met him and [__] like that
um he knew a lot about it because they
said he could Converse about you know
his studies and everything like that
because even when he was in high school
and [__] like that like everybody said
he was super smart and he was a really
good student and stuff like he was real
conscientious but
yeah
yeah uh so it's a whole it's a whole
thing whatever yeah
so yeah so it wasn't even two months
later after Don basem she was the 13
year old after she got killed uh this
was June 9th 1969.
uh some teenage boys came across yet
another body
this one was partially nude uh again
another young woman it was in a field
next to uh an abandoned farmhouse on a
road called North Territorial Road
um this victim had again uh multiple
stab wounds to the body uh two of the
stab wounds had pierced her heart which
I believe that was the cause of death
also she had a gunshot wound to her
forehead
and her neck had been cut almost she had
almost been decapitated like it went
almost all the way through to her spine
um the victim's thumb was also shot off
so they think that the guy like came up
with her then that she put her hand up
like that and it blew her thumb off as
well
um because they figured it was like
Point Blank right uh she had been raped
also but they could not determine
whether this happened while she was
alive or after she was dead
um they did find most of her clothing it
was kind of scattered around
however one of her shoes was missing
which again
he kept trophies which like I said a lot
of serial killers do that
this particular young woman was uh the
following day identified as a 21 year
old University of Michigan graduate
student and her name was Alice Calum now
she had actually disappeared uh not too
long after midnight on June 8th she was
actually last seen uh she had been at a
party like a friend had a party like not
too far away and she was walking back to
her apartment
now they found like in this obviously he
couldn't take the victims to his
abandoned Farmhouse anymore because it
had burned down but when they kind of
fanned out and looked around they did
find this
um Gravel Pit nearby
and they found a bunch of blood stains
and a couple of buttons that had come
off of her raincoat so they determined
that this Gravel Pit is where he killed
her and then he went and dumped her like
later on she had to go to the ground a
bit because he lost his other place yeah
now the fact that this young woman had
been shot in the head with a 22. because
remember how I said Jane mixer who again
spoiler alert they found out later on
through DNA that someone else had done
that but so they were even back then
they were kind of like we're not
entirely sure that this is the same
perpetrator but you know they're kind of
similar so we're kind of leaving it in
the room in the in the roster
um but and well because she'd been shot
right and she hadn't been mutilated or
anything but because this woman had been
shot among other things she had been
mutilated and stabbed and stuff like
that as well but she had also been shot
so they're like oh well maybe
maybe Jane mixer maybe that was the same
guy because you know now he's shooting
people too with the same caliber
thing so they weren't real sure so uh
but this was something that kind of like
gave them pause I guess because this
victim had been shot and some of the
other ones were not
so at this point
um you'd probably not be surprised to
hear that you know all the college
students around us were just freaking
the [__] out and there was like a huge
public outcry like I said uh the media
were really like riding the cops hard
that they hadn't caught this
[__] yet
and
um you know particularly female students
at both of the colleges were just like
pretty nobody would hitchhike anymore
that's like they went everywhere in big
groups and [__] like that because you
know this [__] was out there and
they couldn't catch him uh they also had
a reward going for information and back
then in 1969 it was forty two thousand
dollars which I looked up and that's
like more than 340 thousand dollars like
in today's money so that's how [__]
serious they were about it so you know I
wonder how many how often they [__]
people over out of their out of that
reward
I always wonder about that because you
never really hear about like oh that's
not why we caught him you know some [__]
like that they're probably always come
up with sometimes well we caught them
because of like police work so we're not
gonna give you
I always wonder if like because they
always like offer all these big rewards
and stuff and it's like I always wonder
if anybody ever gets that yeah
not like I ever looked at any specific
case but
um okay
so the last murder that has been
attributed to this [__]
was an 18 year old young woman named
Karen beinemann hold on she was shot in
the head though this last one right uh
no not the last one the the previous one
the second last one okay with the 22
yeah
yeah okay yeah they but they didn't know
that at the time
um they just they weren't sure if it was
around because that Jane mixer she had
been shot twice in the head
um but she wasn't mutilated or anything
like that but there were other
similarities that they thought well
maybe it could be the same guy but maybe
not you know they weren't sure
for people who don't live in the United
States 22 long rifle especially at this
that's what they're talking about it's a
little bitty cartridge it's basically
like a almost a glorified BB gun really
pellet rifle an air pellet rifle can
actually kind of match that performance
at certain ranges but
in those days that you said shot with a
22 that [__] was common as [__] you
could go to you could go to Sears and
Roebuck and get a for just 30 or 40
dollars gonna get a single shot 22 long
rifle yeah Ben said we have 22s overseas
now
I'm just saying here in those days they
were just [__] everywhere
so it's almost like
not real compelling evidence
because those things were just so common
I mean it wasn't just that there were
like some other like where her body was
found like the fact she was a student
like the fact that she had accepted a
ride with somebody she didn't know and
it's like all this other kind of stuff
so there were other similarities but
yeah the wounds and stuff weren't the
same she was just shot and that was it
and I think actually 22 long rifle is
less common now
in the United States than nine
millimeter nine millimeters more common
and 22 is not as cheap as it used to
shoot used to be the shoe
so it you know I think nine millimeter
was the king now probably for the for
calibers in the United States
in terms of just sheer numbers of them
out there
Ian says if I was writing this as a book
I would make him accidentally kill the
first girl and confide in his uncle the
cop yeah we'll get into that uh and his
uncle did the rest of the killing and
frame to nephew yeah we'll get to that
because uh his because you obviously
know about this case because yeah his
uncle was a cop
um so yeah so this is the last murder
like I said Karen beinemann she was also
a student Eastern Michigan University or
emu she was actually last seen on July
23rd
no excuse me
damn
throat's getting all scratchy
um 1969.
so her roommate actually reported her
missing
what um she had done was she had gone
downtown
to go to this wig shop she had ordered
like a like a hair piece not a whole wig
but like a like a hair fall or something
like that you kind of clip into the back
to make your hair look longer or
whatever so she had um ordered that and
went down there to pick it up
so that was the last time she was seen
it it was like the middle of the day it
was like noon or one or something like
that
three days after she disappeared and her
roommate reported her missing they found
her body uh again found nude they found
her in like some Woods like down a gully
um next to the Huron River Parkway
she had also been horribly beaten mostly
about the face and also like the top
half of the body
um she also had like a bunch of
lacerations on her body that were like
really deep like so much that it had
opened the skin up
um like some of the skin had come off
uh also extensive
skull and brain injuries uh inflicted
with a blunt instrument
also she had been forced to drink a
caustic substance
um uh the implication being later on
when they found it later on that I think
it was ammonia
um the killer had also poured the
ammonia or the caustic substance
whatever it was all over her breasts and
nipples like burning them and all over
her neck and shoulders
um also had taken a section of uh cloth
like torn off some of her clothing and
stuffed it down in her trachea to keep
it from screaming while he was keep her
from screaming while he was doing all
this stuff
um so the cause of death officially
according to the pathologist was the
strangulation but he also said that the
wounds to her head were so severe that
it would have killed her if the
strangulation had not
they also couldn't have been conscious I
well I don't had injuries now um she had
also been raped uh and they were able to
determine that she had still been alive
when that had happened
also um he had torn off her underwear
and stuffed it up her vagina
now interestingly and this was one of
the things that ended up well not
necessarily getting him caught but this
was one of the big like things of
evidence that
ended up getting him convicted
so when they extracted her underwear uh
they found semen on it like I said you
know which would have been good nowadays
but back then they didn't have DNA or
anything however they did find over 500
clippings of human hair like little
Clips as though it had been uh cut off
with like a Clipper you know what I mean
now all of these hairs in the underwear
were blonde now she was dark-haired
and obviously the killer which they
found out later on was also dark-haired
so they couldn't figure out where these
hairs had come from
so but we'll get into that a little bit
later well that's what they thought at
first too but that's not what ended up
happening all right
so what they decided to do on and this
was a good idea but it didn't quite work
out the way they wanted
so they found this girl's body like in
this Gully
and they said okay what they had wanted
to do before they said well we know that
the killer has returned to the other
bodies so we want to stake this out
right they wanted to do it with the last
two cases but
um you know the news media had broken
the story like before they could because
they said we want to keep everything
like under wraps we want like a media
blackout so that nobody knows where the
body is so that the killer will come
back thinking that we haven't found it
yet right so they tried to do that with
the last two but it didn't work out
because like I said the the news leaked
out but this one they were actually able
to do it and it's kind of [__] up
because they found the body and they
didn't tell the parents of this poor
girl that they had found her body for
like hours and hours and hours because
they didn't want anybody to know so they
could stake it out and see if the killer
came back that's reasonable though I'm
gonna go ahead yeah and it's just kind
of like well because I was reading about
it like I said they didn't they don't
say this like on most of the things but
I read a book about it and they were
talking about they talked to all the
cops and stuff and I can see how that
would be upsetting and like some of the
cops were like man we should really tell
the parents it's really [__] up that
we found this body and it's like they
don't know like they still think that
their daughter is missing or whatever
and um but some of them were added
they're like look we're pretty sure that
this guy we gotta stake this out we're
gonna see how this goes like I said it
didn't work out
but that's not really their fault it was
a good idea
so what they did
um they're like We're Not Gonna Leave
the [__] body there what we'll do is
we'll take the body because they said
that's just disrespectful or whatever so
they did take the body away
but then they brought in like a
mannequin like they went to like a
JCPenney or something and they posed the
mannequin there yeah and put it and then
they hid like they had all the cops like
hide around right that's yeah so like I
said it wasn't it wasn't a bad idea it
was a good idea
and it would have worked out because
what happened was so all the cops are
kind of like hiding and they only have
the radios and stuff like that but then
the weather got super shitty like it
started like raining and all this other
kind of crap and then it got dark and
they couldn't really see and then one of
the cops who was kind of like behind
behind this tree or whatever saw a guy
like a young guy running from the site
yeah so they think well they think that
this was him and that he came there to
like see but they don't know if he
touched the body they don't think he did
because they didn't get any prints off
it because they did check the mannequin
for Prince later
um but they think that he did come back
to see it and maybe saw it and freaked
out and like ran away or something like
that but they didn't get a good look at
him you know the weather was really bad
and then like the cop like tried to
radio it in but the weather was so bad
that the radios weren't working like it
was all kind of like [__] up and they
couldn't really hear so it's like pretty
much just this one cop is like I'm
pretty sure I saw a young guy like
running away from the scene and that was
probably him but they and then they kind
of fanned out and they tried to find him
and [__] like that but they couldn't
find him so like I said when the media
found out about this they just like ran
you know they ran them through the
ringer but like I said I don't think
that's a bad idea I think that was
actually a really good idea I mean the
fact that it didn't work out I don't
think that was really their fault you
know what I mean I think a lot of that
was weather and
whatever I don't think it was anything
that they did necessarily because it was
a good idea and it does seem like the
guy like came back like they thought he
would they just didn't see him and they
couldn't catch him that's all it was
so uh so yeah
sadly that that did not work out but it
didn't take that much longer to find him
so what they ended up doing was they go
to the wig shop where this uh were the
last victim uh went to like before she
disappeared
and they asked the lady that owned it
whose name was um Diana gauche I think
is how you pronounce her last name I'm
not sure if it's ghost or it's
g-o-s-h-e so that could be gauche gashi
Goshi could be lots of different things
so I'll just call her Diana
yeah she said
yeah she came in here
um to pick up her wig thing it was
twenty dollars uh she came in the early
afternoon and she's like and
interestingly outside of the shop
waiting for her
was a young man with dark hair parted on
the side like a handsome dude
um he was wearing a horizontal striped
shirt or sweater and he was sitting on a
blue motorcycle outside like like he was
waiting for her
now interestingly the victim here said
to the woman that owned the wig shop
she's like I'm doing she said I'm
paraphrasing but she said something like
oh I'm doing some stuff I never thought
that I would do you know and they're
like what are you talking about she's
like oh I'm buying a wig oh and also I
accepted a ride from this stranger like
she would never normally do that but she
was doing it today she's like oh I'm
being crazy it was that kind of [__]
um apparently like the woman that owned
the wig shop said something like that
that the girl said to her I've got to be
either the bravest or the dumbest girl
alive because I've just accepted a ride
from this guy
so they actually got a decent look at
him and the Motorcycle
now Diana who owned the wig shop she
initially she's like I don't know a huge
amount about motorcycles she thought it
was a Honda 350.
but when they asked this other woman
that worked and I think it was like a
chocolate shop that was like next to the
wig shop that woman was real into
motorcycles and she's like no no it was
a Triumph like she's like yeah she's
like it was blue and she like described
it really well because she was really
into motorcycles so it was it was a
trance Bonneville yeah
now the description that they gave
um was actually overheard by another cop
that was there who was a patrolman his
name was Larry Mathewson oh hold on one
second what's that reason why the girl
thought that the other one was Honda
350s because Hannah made a thing called
a 305 I think it was called a 305
Nighthawk back in the 60s looked just
like a bottle well that's what she
thought it was that's what I think
that's what she thought it was but she
said she wasn't sure she just said it
she thought it was maybe a Honda and it
was a blue yeah yeah there was a Honda
that looked just like that yeah I think
they even took her in the other and the
other woman that worked at the wig shop
who had also seen the guy they even took
them to like a Honda dealership to see
if they could pick something out that
looked like the bike you know what I
mean it was called 305 Super hawk or 305
Nighthawk or so it was a copy of the
Bonneville
yeah because the Japanese loved the
Bonneville they wanted their own
so Honda made a little replica yeah but
the but the girl in the shop next door
which I'm pretty sure was a chocolate
shop but she said yeah that was a
Triumph yeah she noticed it for you for
all these I'm talking about it was
fonzi's motorcycle
yeah there you go see I don't even
remember what yeah look like although I
used to I used to really like happy days
but I remember correctly wrote a
Bonneville
so yeah so while the women in the wig
shop were describing this dude to the
cops like I said one of the um cops that
was there was like a patrolman Larry
Matheson
and the way they were describing the
dude like they did like some sketches of
him they weren't great but they I mean
it kind of looked like him though
this guy thought man that description
sounds just like a guy who used to be in
my frat uh who's it was Theta chai I
think was the Frat that he was in and
he's like and his name is John Norman
Collins
now he knew that that guy had that
Collins had been interviewed previously
but they had you know not really checked
up and they just thought it wasn't him
and this particular patrolman it so
happened had actually seen John Norman
Collins like I said he knew him he had
been in the same frat as him like at the
same time
and he's like and I saw that dude riding
his blue Triumph around town on the day
that that girl disappeared like he he
you know he just remembered it
so he actually went to Collins and asked
him about it like you know what were you
up to and there's kind of like a
extensive
um thing about it like in the book where
he was trying to not accuse him I guess
because he didn't really think it was
him because he knew him but he was
trying to kind of like
go around and like kind of say hey did
you see anybody that had a motorcycle
like yours that day or who kind of
looked like you that day like he was
kind of asking him [__] like that
because he said he didn't want him to
like clam up too I don't think he really
thought it was him at that point but he
thought it was him enough that he
thought he would go and ask him about it
so um
so what he said he's like yeah I was
riding my bike around that day it was a
Triumph Bonneville like I said it was
blue and he's like yeah I stopped and
talked to a former girlfriend of his
which they later found out was true
because they went and interviewed her
like a guy a girl he had dated for a
Time
and So eventually they went to that girl
and they asked if she had any recent
photos of him
and it turned out that she did she had
like two pictures of him that were like
of him standing by a Christmas tree or
some [__] like that that were only a few
months old
so she loaned them to the cops and then
the cops went back to the wig shop and
said was this the guy that you saw
and they were pretty sure that that was
him
um so there was that
now they knew that he owned two triumphs
he had a blue one and a green one and he
had a couple of other motorcycles too
but I don't remember what they were they
were some brand that I'd never heard of
like I said he did have a part-time job
um it was kind of a like a factory type
place they made like drum breaks or
something like that
um so uh so they kind of went and like
investigated him
now interestingly they asked him they
went to back to his frat brothers and
said well isn't it true that you used to
be in this frat and then now you live by
yourself and when they went back to his
frat they didn't want to really say
anything bad about him at first but like
the more they asked they're like oh well
we actually kicked him out because he
kept stealing [__] like he was
um like a habitual Thief klepto yeah he
was like a kleptomaniac so he kept like
stealing stuff from them so like
eventually they kicked him out but it's
like interesting that they didn't want
to say anything bad about him at first
they were just like oh it just didn't
work out or whatever but then like the
more they asked him they're like uh yeah
he kept stealing [__] from us that's why
we kicked him out so he went and like
moved to his own place
and the more that they like asked other
acquaintances like other people that
knew him they said a lot of people
thought that he was an okay dude they
said he was really nice he was really
like cool around women everything like
that but then there were a few people
that thought that he was
um uh one person called him oversexed
that was a word that was thrown around
um and also said that he had like a hair
trigger temper like he was normal but
like if he got mad like he would just
like [__] turn on a dime like that
and he'd get like really mad and it
would surprise you you know what I mean
because he wasn't normally like that
um there was also an instance
where he allegedly uh
was with a woman like I'm assuming it
was he was on a date and she didn't want
to have sex with him and he raped her
anyway
she didn't go to the cops which well nor
um I hate to tell you but even nowadays
and especially back then a lot of it is
not reported yeah the girl doesn't want
to carry that around that's what I mean
so a lot of even nowadays people don't
uh report it all that often yeah and
back then it was probably like a lot
worse we know a girl like that yeah we
got raped by three or four Dudes
they picked her up
she was sitting on a temp this is when
she was younger she but she told a bunch
of people
and they never treated her the same way
again they treated like she was like a
mentally ill or damaged or some [__]
like that that's what I mean and it's
like you wonder it's like I'm you know
what it's like I don't know I like to
think that if that had happened to me I
would reported it but I don't know if I
would she told me the whole story I
don't know if I would she told me the
whole story and a lot of people won't
yeah so it's a lot more common than you
think because a lot of people don't
report it yeah but she hadn't reported
it apparently but they found out later
like just through the great friend like
asking people around you
um so they also asked some of his former
girlfriends because it was a lot like I
said he always he didn't have any
trouble getting women he always had ones
like you bring them home on the weekends
and stuff and like his roommates were
like wow bro like way to pull you know
what I mean but it was that but a couple
of his former girlfriends did say
that if uh you were on your period then
he'd get really really mad
and uh and that was something that a lot
of them had oh my God how dare you had
noticed how dare you one girl in
particular said she had been and I guess
she had been kind of casually like
dating him for a bit yeah and it's like
they were either outside the apartment
or they were in the apartment and he was
like started like you know groping on
her boobs or whatever and then he pulled
back and said are you on your period and
she's like yeah and he was like that's
disgusting and then like he stormed out
and she's like
okay you know what I mean and then work
around that and then she did it and then
she didn't see him again I was like well
that was [__] he's not the kind of
bullet dodged he's not the kind of guy
to get his blood wings I guess not
you know what it's like I know this is
gross but I do have kind of like a lot
of admiration for a dude that will just
like plunge right in there you know what
I don't care yeah I don't care
[Laughter]
I respect that I respect that my ex-wife
said that was the best sex of the
[__] world was beyond a [__] rat
he's just [__] pound the [__] out of
her I mean honestly it depends
um you know I don't I don't have that
anymore because like I said I'm older
now but um but when I was usually like
the first day or two it's like I didn't
feel like doing [__] [__] much less
like I was just like I just want to lay
here and cry is what I mostly want to do
because it hurts so bad no Tiff had
asked me for help
I had to come to the rescue well I've
heard that I've heard that it does
alleviate yeah but I I just never felt
good enough to like she said I just
never felt alleviate all the cramping
I've heard that yeah but like I said I
always felt so shitty yeah like the
first day or two that I'm just like I
don't even feel like doing anything I
just couldn't even stand upright that
was how bad the pain was she
girl she kind of into [__] she you
kind of our sexual our sex back in those
days the gothic sexual sexual
orientation was bondage that was the
same and then well I mean it still is to
some extent and the [__] uh she said
the pain pleasure mixture would [__]
just send her over the [__] roof she
[__] loved it yeah I get it yeah but
like I said like I said that the clap
cramps would be alleviated yeah you feel
a lot better I didn't usually [__] with
it because like I said the first day or
two it's just like I didn't feel like
doing anything because I felt so [__]
gross and in such pain and stuff but I
had heard that I never had it never
really [__] bothered me
but see I that's because a lot of dudes
are grossed out by it and I'm just like
dude it's just you know and I'm you know
I'm not gonna lie it's like look I've
experienced this [__] for decades it is
kind of gross but it's just kind of like
you can't you gotta deal with it you
gotta deal with it nowhere near what a
dude thinks it's not that bad it's not
that bad I mean really it's really not
gonna leave [__] red rings and fun I
mean you just gotta like take some
precautions you don't want to like stay
in some [__] but you know what I mean
it's not that big of a deal I have done
it before like on the right but you know
what I mean but like I said if you have
one of those Diva cups or something like
that like you know we've done it before
like when I had a cop up there yeah and
I think it's funny that you know like
some of these retro dudes had these
[__] pretty retro [__] Hang-Ups
and it wasn't just Maniacs you had guys
that were [__] top-notch society
[__] Howard Hughes or Howard Hughes
was [__] rich guy he was open-minded
[__] he was all in the [__]
avionics and for Aviation you know and
all kinds of stuff and he just thought
going down on a chick was
[__] some wild [__] you know what I
mean and uh he thought that [__] was
wild as a [__] he thought that
was like which I mean now it's just kind
of like you better do that
evidently asked to check the douche
first
like he's worried about that oh he's
gonna get like germs well yeah he wanted
to do it but you had to [__] douche
first
hey maybe he thought that you might get
sick or some or something but anyway
well he was like germaphobic and honest
and don't and don't douche because
that'll like [__] yeah they used to tell
you to do that but it's like that's
really bad for you [__] wanna make
his long story short they found a
[__] the story behind this damn box
was pretty awesome I read a whole book
written by a guy named Dietrich who was
his right hand man who ran his Empire
for him he hired him off the street he
was just a boxer he didn't trust lawyers
or any [__] anybody with a college
degree did you [__] trust you
might be something to be said about that
though especially even back in those
days
and um
he
Hughes disappeared he was out in the
wild nobody knew where he was for like
about a year
and he came back with this box told him
to hide the Box a couple years later
[__] the Box got water on it they
opened it up to see what it was
and it was a bunch of Red Rider comic
books and a whole bunch of douches with
[__] wrapped up and folded nicely
with dates written on them like [__]
100 douches dude was a weirdo so he was
going down on chips and recorded it and
like and keeping the trophies and [__]
so that he knows how much how much how
much [__] he was licking I mean
[__] Howard man I guess and he did
that as a poor guy he didn't you know
because he would run from his own money
and live as a poor guy for like a year
at a time yeah crazy crazy [__]
yeah Ben said Hughes was very worried
about blood yeah yeah Ian said it's just
young dudes that don't have experience
it was gnarly the first time and after
that you good yeah
we did a show on Hughes you guys can go
back to the catalog and watch him uh I
had a lot of respect for Howard Hughes I
have a lot of I think he was a good man
a lot of head injuries
and OCD that was that was his day yeah
he had he had issues and uh he didn't
work after the people but he was an
intelligent guy very good looking and
[__] for his for his era especially
like the 30s and [__] in the 40s he was
[__] he was King as a young man on an
RKO Studios RKO pictures and he he did
have some idiosyncrasies about him but
a lot of guys have idiosyncrasies well
everyone does and for his time
uh his he wasn't weird
he got weird later on after all those
head injuries that's true but no he's a
regular guy or not I'm gonna say a
regular guy he was
[__] one of the coolest [__]
Rich guys really for his era
Ben says uh they are all right though
menstrual bleeding is gross you need to
stay away till it's gone and then wifey
posted women are built for life for good
or eel good or ill deal yeah I'm always
just kind of like look I like I said I
went through it for decades and it is a
little bit gross but it's like it's not
you have to deal with it I you know
starting when you're 12 years old and
some girls start earlier than that I was
about average in that regard but um you
know and I went through it until I was
what 49 something like that 48.49 uh so
you have to go through just every and
actually mine was closer together so a
lot of people's you know 28 days mine
was three weeks apart so every three
weeks
I would have that [__] happen unless I
was on the pill and then it was more
regulated but you just kind of it's not
great but you got to deal with it and I
always like and I know dudes are grossed
out by a lot of dudes are gross out by
it but I always have like a lot of
respect for dudes that are not grossed
out by it because
yeah it's kind of gross but what are you
gonna do it's like you can't do anything
about it it's just like a bodily
function you know
and I get but I totally respect like if
people don't want to have sex on it and
stuff like that that's fine it's like
I'm not bothered by that I'm not saying
oh you have to or anything like that but
I do have like respect for dudes that
aren't grossed out but it'll be like I
don't care you know what I mean because
Don's like I don't care you know what I
mean
I think it was more me that was just
kind of like I don't I don't really feel
that good so it's like I'm not gonna do
it but
but he wasn't bothered and he was just
like man whatever it's it's like I've
been through it all before it's okay
um but yeah so so there's that we're
yeah so this guy
I don't know he seemed to have like a
weird
aversion like you know more than normal
I would guess where he just thought it
was like completely disgusting and maybe
he was one of those dudes that like
thought you could like stop it and like
we were doing it on purpose or something
I'm like look bro
if we could stop it we would
um you know why do you think like some
chicks like I said would just take birth
control pills all the time to keep it
from doing it so because we don't like
it either we don't like it any more than
you do
um but yeah
so so they found that out when they
interviewed man I might need another
drink
while you're well while you're walking
around what do you think we have on the
show
um not that long because I want to eat
afterwards I'm gonna reheat some of that
stuff oh okay well it's okay we don't
you know it's it's not like I have to
get up at five in the morning like I
normally would we are gonna work on
streamate tomorrow but we can just start
that whenever
but yeah so so after they found out
about some of the um some of his
girlfriends like saying stuff about how
the weird thing that he had about
periods
they also started asking like some of
his uh co-workers like at the factory
that he works at and a couple of them
said yeah he was really into describing
um the bodies that they found like in
super graphic detail especially to the
other women that work there
and they found out like just from
interviewing some of the women that some
of the details that he told them had
actually not been released to the media
so they thought that was kind of
interesting that he knew some of that
stuff and he would it seemed like I
don't know if they said this out right
but it seemed like he was kind of like
getting off on describing
like the the [__] up [__] that had
happened to the bodies like and
especially describing it to the women
because I guess he liked them being
gross out or shocked or whatever
now he said when they asked him about
this he said oh I knew about that
because my uncle whose name is David
Leake I think is how you pronounce his
last name
he was a sergeant in the police force
and he told me now his uncle was a cop
uh was a sergeant
now they found out it's like so the
stuff that he was describing like what
the injuries of the body were and stuff
like that which they hadn't told the
media
um that was what happened to them so so
either he knew or but he said oh my
uncle told me so they went and asked the
uncle and he was like yeah I wouldn't
have told anybody that so I don't know
where he's getting that from
now
um as they looked further into it they
also found out that and I think I
alluded to this earlier but that Collins
even if he didn't know know the victims
he for sure lived in close proximity to
like a bunch of them
um he had like the first victim who was
uh Mary fledger
and the second victim who is Joan shell
um he had actually lived either across
the street or like next door like so he
lived like on the same street as the two
of them
um and actually Mary fledger the first
victim he actually worked because he had
um a job like on campus and she did too
he actually worked in an office right
across the hall from hers so he would
have seen her presumably like pretty
much every day or whenever he was
working
um it also turned out that he had had a
former girlfriend who lived right across
the street from the 13 year old victim
Don basem so and he went to visit this
girlfriend all the time so it was
presumed that he had seen this girl at
some point so even though he maybe
wasn't stalking stalking them the it
seemed like most of the victims were
girls and women that he had seen in the
vicinity you know what I mean and he was
just kind of like oh I'm gonna get that
one or whatever so it was that
now they also asked the woman at the uh
wig shop like I said the the two women
at the wig shop they came in with they
brought John uh Collins in and they put
him in a lineup because they had already
looked at the photos and they said yeah
that looks like him so they brought in
the lineup and they're like okay yeah
that's definitely him and then they
ended up finding like a whole bunch of
other Witnesses who had actually seen
who they thought was him in that sweater
on that motorcycle like in that area
when uh when vitamin disappeared so
there was that as well and also they
found out that that same day that she
disappeared a bunch of other women came
forward and said yeah that guy that
looked like that in the striped shirt on
the blue Triumph he came up and tried to
get me to ride on the back of his
motorcycle and I said no so he had been
cruising around trying to pick girls up
that particular day and she was just the
one that accepted the ride I guess uh
much to her detriment
so they went to this motherfucker's
apartment
on July 27 1969. uh he had a roommate
whose name was Arnold Davis
now when they came in there Collins was
like I absolutely don't know any of
these people I didn't do anything bloody
blah they said why don't you come back
and take a lie detector test and he
would not do that
now they didn't really have enough to
arrest him or hold him on or anything
like that they were just kind of like
questioning him however they found out
later on that his roommate later told
them that then the either the that night
or the next night after they had asked
him to come take a polygraph and he
wouldn't take it
his roommate said he came out of his
room and had this box that kind of had
part of a blanket over it but like the
blanket sort of slipped off while he was
carrying it and they said inside this
box was
a single woman's shoe that was kind of
purple or maroon colored
um some kind of like something rolled up
that kind of looked like a pair of jeans
um and a burlap purse
and so the so he takes that stuff out
the apartment like later on his roommate
is like bro what the [__] was that all
about and the guy's like oh I just it
was just some stuff I decided to get rid
of
um so yeah
uh spoiler alert they will find out
later on that that was stuff that
belonged to some of the victims and he
was getting rid of it they never defined
it though so they don't know if he
burned it or what
so David Leake who was a sergeant and
who was um for the State Police and he
was this dude's uncle
it turned out that he had actually been
on him and his wife and kids he had
three kids I think three sons and they
had been on vacation
at the time that binderman disappeared
and they had given Collins the key to
the house to come in there and feed
their dog while they were gone because
they were gone for a couple weeks or
whatever so he was only one with the key
to the house he would come in there and
feed the dog and [__] like that
now they came home
um three days after the last victim was
discovered like her body was discovered
and what happened was that they went
down to
um the basement or you know the
Sergeant's wife who I think her name was
Sandra she went down to the basement and
she noticed some [__] missing like
nothing important but she's like I had
like a empty box of like laundry
detergent I had a bottle of ammonia down
here and now it's gone and then they
noticed that there was like black spray
paint like on the floor and they're like
that definitely was not there before so
what the [__] is that all about
um and the and the can of blacks play
spray paint that had been in there was
also gone so they thought that was a
little bit weird black he spray painted
her well no not necessarily okay no it
wasn't it wasn't that
wasn't that first one okay no no no he
said she was good no she was she was
black because she was uh rotten okay
like I said they found out later because
remember where I said that Farmhouse
that burned down later they found a
place that they thought that the body
had been laying where it's just kind of
like it was real shaded and cool like in
this one spot and then this one spot
like had sun coming in the thing and
they think that was where the body was
laying because it looked like the same
configuration teenagers didn't find it
huh weird yeah
I guess I like I said it was a big place
and I don't really know if um you know
it might have been a while and he knew
there was nobody coming out there or
whatever
so at this point they tell so the cops
tell uh David Leake they're like look
we hate to tell you this but your nephew
who they loved him I mean obviously they
trusted him to come in there they gave
him the key to their house and feed
their dog and [__] like that and
especially the wife Sandra she was like
a mother to him because he was kind of
estranged from his mom yeah so he always
considered these two like his kind of
more his real parents like he hung out
there all the time and he played with
their kids and whatnot so they just
loved him and they couldn't believe it
so um so the cops told him they're like
look um you know your nephew is a
suspect
and um they kind of told him what they
had against him at that point which
wasn't a huge amount but it was still
like pretty you know it was still like
pretty interesting
now he didn't tell them at this point
because he didn't think anything about
it he didn't tell them tell him that
there was like [__] missing from the
base because it wasn't anything valuable
like I said this is a bottle of ammonia
and it was like a pain right and he's
like well maybe somebody broke in even
though he looked around the house and
there was no sign of force entry or
anything like that so he's like well
maybe it was him that did it but it's
probably like an innocent explanation
like he didn't think anything about it
but then the next day
um this art he got kind of like
suspicious about it so he talked to one
of the other cops and they said well
we'll go back to the basement and see so
they scraped some of the black spray
paint up
and there was some [__] underneath there
that kind of looked like blood
so they were like okay so at this point
David Lee goes to the cops and says I
found something it's like I think it
might be blood like you guys need to
come and like check this out so like I
said mad respect because the student's
nephew and like I said
as soon as he thought something was
fishy he's like come in here and check
this out because it's odd because yeah
so he used spray paint to high blood
hide a blood stain well we're gonna see
yeah we'll see
so yeah so he gets everybody to come in
the cops come in
so they do like a huge uh and they try
to be sneaky about it because they
didn't want to tip him off because they
knew they didn't have enough evidence to
hold Collins on a murder charge yeah so
they were just kind of like well we
don't want him to really like he kind of
knows he's a suspect but we don't want
him to know that we know all of this
stuff so they kind of had to like park
around the block and [__] like that so
they all come in there like on the down
low and like check out the basement
right now it turned out
that the stains that have been covered
by the black paint were actually not
blood they were actually like varnish
and when they told them this like they
did the forensic analysis of it or
whatever and when they told David Lake
this the sergeant he was like oh [__] I
remember like I spilled varnish on the
floor like I was painting the window
panes or something like that and [__]
like that but then he's like but wait
why would he spray paint over varnish
unless he thought it was blood yeah you
know what I'm saying and he's like so
that looks even more suspicious yeah and
so then they're like because at first
they were just kind of like oh well it's
not blood but then they kind of like
started looking around even more and
then they found a bunch of little hair
clippings
remember how that one victim had all
those hair clippings like 500 hair
clippings in her underwear that had been
shoved up in her vagina yeah that didn't
belong to her obviously because they
were short and blonde so they found all
these hair clippings down there and
they're like what the [__] is this and
so the sergeant says oh my wife Cuts our
little kids hair down here
um you know so that's where the hair
would have come and they're like oh and
at this point like the sergeant because
he was State Police he didn't know that
they had found all those hairs like in
that girl's underwear down there yeah
that's where he killed her in his uncle
and aunt's house basement yeah they know
that that's where he killed the kid
because there was like a bunch of hair
transfer he's like yeah our our wife
like cuts her brings down the little
shaver thing and like Cuts all the kids
hair down here and said it actually cut
it before we went on vacation because
like I said they were gone for like two
weeks he didn't see the hair on the
ground she probably sweeped a lot swept
a lot of it up but they're probably yeah
so so yeah so they asked about that so
they're like oh [__] and then when they
looked even more they did find some
blood stains yeah um they were small but
they were big enough that they could
type them and it turned out
because someone was like on the side of
the washer or something like that and
they found out that the blood that they
found in there was type a uh which was
the same kind as Karen vitamin who was
the last victim so they think that's
where she was uh killed
so yeah they did a forensic analysis on
the hairs found in her underwear and the
ones found in the basement and were uh
perfect match
also they interviewed all of
um the neighbors around there and a
couple of them said that they had seen
Collins leaving the house with the
laundry detergent box I don't know what
he did with that because I think I think
the wife said it was empty but he
definitely took the ammonia and I think
that's what he used on that um victim as
well also one of the um neighbors
thought they had heard like a woman
screaming but like muffled kind of like
coming from yeah the house like at some
point about stuffing
brags got in their throats I think
that's postmortem
because that alone would kill you I'd
have to see how far down they're talking
about yeah and she would just spit it
out if she was fighting I think that was
done post-mortem it might have been and
um the same thing with the with the uh
the ammonia that was probably post more
of them he's probably trying to clean
evidence off of her
that I think that was the first one that
he had although like I said he was real
into like torture in the sense that a
lot of the victims like he slashed their
breasts and [__] like that so he might
have been like trying out something new
you know semen down in her mouth she
would have been giving him head earlier
and he turns on her
he worries about it after he kills her
he pours on a dead or throat maybe try
to destroy it
but what was funny is that there wasn't
any DNA they didn't know about DNA back
then no this is the late 60s they didn't
know any of that back then you can't get
a living person to swallow a bunch of
[__]
caustic material they'd throw it right
back up
but think
I'm not really sure it was probably
something I'm not willing to say
anything I think he's a definitive about
that yeah he's torturing beating him up
but then after they're dead he's doing
more to him that's what I think
yeah I mean they do think that he did
some [__] because she's dead in the
basement he's doing this to her she's
got to go upstairs and go get that
ammonia no it was in the basement it was
in the basement yeah it was just
something he saw he grabbed yeah it was
like down with the because that was like
where the laundry [__] was and
everything so the wife had in the thing
of ammonia because she noticed that it
was gone yeah like when they came back
from vacation she's gonna be laying
there semi-conscious minimum
because he's been beating on her so bad
didn't he Crush her skull in yeah most
of them had like real bad and that's
what killed her crushing the skull yeah
I'll go
it's [__] up
yeah and you know
any rag that's in her mouth she's gonna
spill it spit it out if she if it's down
in her throat or trachy I'd have to see
like how far down they're talking
she'd be suffocating anyway wouldn't
matter if you were
well you I guess you could breathe
through your nose but no I think if you
get an airway blockage down there you
can really breathe through your nose can
you
yeah so
I'm just can't all be happening to her
at once this is
well no I'm sure it's like a prolonged
yeah and I think some of it is after
she's dead he's stuffing things in her
throat and putting things up in her
badge
I mean the body having fun with it or
whatever
yeah like I said that's also not great
but yeah but yeah I think he killed her
by hitting her in the head with a
[__] boom because even even if that
doesn't kill you that massive head
trauma you'd be out
or you'd only be semi-conscious I mean I
hope I hope yeah that they didn't really
know what's happening yeah yeah but I
mean you never know because some people
have gone through like some horrible
[__] torture
Consciousness
well she was struggling they know that
right so she was alive being stabbed I
mean I've known people that have been
stabbed before they said they don't even
know that they got stabbed they thought
they got punched yeah that's pretty
common for people
and stabbing is not very effective
that's why they're stabbed so many times
you know it's not like in the movies
where you stab a person once and then
they just follow the dead no you want to
hear something I didn't even know that
happened a case that I wrote about which
as far as I know is still unsolved yeah
um I think it was a little girl what was
her name I think her name was Wendy
Wallen and she was just walking down the
street like her mom was bringing the car
around like they just been to the mall
or some [__] like that this happened
back in the 60s I think it was 16. how
old are you talking about
um she was
um
I can't remember 11 12 like she yeah
little girl
walking down the street like her mom was
bringing the car around like from the
parking garage
and a dude just walked by and just
stabbed her in the stomach and then just
kept on walking yeah and she lived for a
while like they took her to the hospital
and she said a dude punched me in the
stomach she said a guy punch me in the
stomach but it wasn't he had stabbed him
with a hunting knife and she died later
like from her internal injuries yeah and
they never did catch that [__]
either yeah as far as I know
was her name but yeah she that so that
just reminded me of that that she said
somebody punched me in the stomach that
was what she said yeah like when
everybody ran over yeah she's like that
guy this dude just ran off yeah he just
ran off it ran off no like people chased
him but they they couldn't catch him
they couldn't catch him yeah he was they
and they think that he stabbed someone
else earlier on like he was rocking
around stabbing people like a crazy
person yeah but like I said I think this
was about I can't remember what city it
was in but he was doing it at random
yeah it seemed like yeah yeah he's just
like a [__] nut yeah but I don't
think they ever caught him
but yeah so um so at that point so they
searched the house and they're like okay
well that's that's pretty good and at
this point Collins is in custody but he
calls in the Lord like his mom is just
kind of like she was kind of a Karen and
she's just like in there being like oh
this is my baby and he didn't do it so
she's like already calling a lawyer
don't say anything and she's doing all
this other kind of [__] and that I mean
to be fair the cops knew that they
didn't really necessarily have enough to
hold him on so they were just kind of
like we can only hold him for how many
hours it is
um so we really want to like have enough
to like arrest him so they were waiting
for the [__] to come back from the lab
like the hair samples and the blood and
everything like that so it's like so we
have something to hold him on so he's
there they go and they tell him
that it's like oh well most of the stuff
that they found underneath the paint was
varnish weirdly when they told him that
he busted out crying yeah and I'm just
like I wonder if it was relief or if he
thought oh well wait now that looks even
more suspicious because obviously he had
taken the paint because they you know
you know they saw him take it or they
know that he took it so it's just kind
of like obviously he thought that was
blood and he's like oh [__] I gotta
cover that up even though it wasn't
blood but they did find some blood other
in another place that wasn't covered
with paint that was like hidden
so I guess he thought oh well [__] I
shouldn't have done that it looked even
more suspicious or he was relieved
because he thought oh now they don't get
me on nothing I'm not really sure
they said he busted out crying but then
he kind of like got his [__] together
and said oh I didn't do anything I
didn't know that chick or whatever
so the thing about it so they're waiting
and waiting and they're just like look
they're they're calling like the people
they're like look can we have the lab
results like we want to hold this dude
we don't want to like let him go and
there's kind of like we don't know which
is you know might not be back yet and
blah blah and like you know Collins and
his mom are there and like the lawyers
there like we're taking him home right
now and all this other kind of [__] and
then finally like the cobbler the you
know district attorney whatever just go
arrest him arrest him it's like you can
arrest him it's fine so they did
so they kept him because like I said
they really did not want him to get away
you know what I mean so they go and
looked through his apartment and all of
his vehicles
uh they did find like a bunch of stolen
stuff like nothing really that had
anything to do with the murders but like
remember how I said he got kicked out of
the Frat because he was like a [__]
klepto yeah they found a bunch of stuff
that he had stolen
and they found out that he had this
friend uh who had formerly lived there
with them he was a roommate whose name
was Andrew Manuel and him like Collins
and Manuel they were quite the little
burglary team they would just go and
like steal [__] all the time
so they but they didn't find anything
having to do so they found a bunch of
that stuff but they didn't find anything
having to do with the murders and also
all they knew about that was that what
his other roommate said like Andrew I
think was his name or um or Arnold
rather
who said yeah he took that box out that
had a shoe in it and jeans and [__] like
that that they're pretty sure was like
stuff from the murder victim so he
destroyed it they never did find that
but so all they had was his word for it
now interestingly what had happened that
they found out later was that Collins
and his other klepto roommate they had
gone to California at the end of June
and when they kind of coordinated with
the cops over there they found out there
was a very similar murder that happened
in California in Salinas a 17 year old
girl named Roxy Ann Phillips uh she had
actually been
um walking around and they saw this dude
she had been walking around with a
friend of hers and they saw this dude
cruising around in a car and he had said
his name was John and then he was from
Michigan and the car had Michigan plates
now they had been staying in this camper
trailer thing they rented it in Michigan
then they drove it to California and
then they just left it there so they
stole it essentially
um they left Collins and his friends
okay yeah yeah so they had driven
announced California that with no
intention of like bringing it back right
so it turned out that while he was in
California there was this murder that
was unsolved right
um they found her body uh July 13th and
it was just like in Carmel like in this
ravine
and her body was kind of mutilated and
[__] like that just like the ones in
Michigan were so when they found out
that this dude was in California at that
time that that happened they're like oh
he probably did that [__] too
now they picked up uh the other guy
Manuel in Arizona but he didn't seem to
know anything about the murders like
they did lie detector and everything
like that he did know about all the
thefts and [__] like that because they
did [__] thefts together but he didn't
seem to know about any of the murders so
they think that Collins did that [__] on
his own you know what I mean
so they put Collins on trial
in June of 1970. now they wanted to
they're pretty sure that he had done
like I said these [__] six seven
murders but they're like well really the
only the the strongest case that we have
is for Karen subinomen there's the most
evidence for that so we're just gonna
pursue that we're not gonna try and like
do the other [__] we just want this dude
off the streets
now interestingly here was I thought
this was interesting too and I read this
in the book so they had this defense
lawyer first
um the first guy that they hired was
this dude named Richard Bryan
but Richard Brian like even though
initially he thought the dude was
innocent like Collins but after a while
like he was talking to him and he's like
I don't know man I think this dude might
have done this [__] so he said I'm gonna
make you take a oh he didn't make him
but he's like would you take a polygraph
like private like not cops I won't tell
anybody what to think but I'm just I
want to know
so he agreed
so Collins took a lie detector test
and then but his lawyer didn't say what
it was but he came out and said
um
I think that you should plead not guilty
by reason of insanity like he basically
said diminish responsibility that's what
it was before he was like oh not guilty
absolutely so at that point everybody's
like oh he must have failed that [__]
polygraph but he wouldn't tell him like
what had happened so uh his mom
Collins's mom got really pissed and
fired that lawyer and got another one
you know what I mean
so uh but yeah apparently the first
defense attorney thought oh my God this
dude did this [__] and it's maybe we
should just tell him you're crazy to try
to get out of this and then like the mom
fired him so that's what happened
so yeah so the whole prosecution thing
like I said they had a lot of they had
the hair evidence they had the blood
evidence they had all of the witnesses
that had seen him picking up Karen Sue
Barnum and like you know before she
disappeared she wasn't seen alive after
that you know at least seven people had
positively identified him with the shirt
and the hair and everything like that so
they had like a lot of uh evidence for
that and then all of the stuff from the
basement like with the paint and all
that kind of stuff
so
um basically all they all the defense
tried to do was say that all of those
witness uh you know the spotting of him
were irony oh that wasn't me or he was
trying to come up with like some other
[__] you know what I mean but it didn't
seem like it was uh you know they tried
to poke holes in the [__] but it didn't
really seem to be easy what does it
matter if the what the defense attorney
thinks the guy is guilty here well a lot
sometimes like just for um it there is
yeah I think well this guy like for
ethical purposes it's like I don't want
to defend this [__] because I
think he might have done it yeah did it
I think it probably depends on state law
but
uh which state you're talking about but
in general
if your attorney believes you to be
guilty he's going to say the only way I
can represent you is if you enter a
guilty purely will fly for this and this
and this right
um
and and if you go no no no I wanna I
wanna not guilty verdict you know what I
mean he's going well you're not you're
guilty you know based on everything
you've read and it's like you're not
going to get the best defense in that I
mean if you're a defense attorney of all
people like things are guilty you're not
going to get the best representation so
then that guy's gonna say you're either
gonna
enter the a plea of Not Guilty by reason
of sanity and we can fight this way or I
have to come off your case and that's
what this guy did he's like I'm pretty
sure after he saw the results whatever
they were of the polygraph he's like I'm
pretty sure this guy did it so he
recommended he's like well plead guilty
but you know yeah insanity or diminished
responsibility or whatever the guy
wouldn't do that so
basically lawyers take an oath to uphold
the law not to [__] subvert it
so
they can't come at you and say look I
know you're guilty we know you know
you're guilty but I'm going to get you
off of this you know by [__] doing it
they're not actually allowed to do that
yeah they're not really supposed to like
I said it's super unethical right and
this guy it seemed like he got fired
like the mom fired him because he was
like look I'll say your attorney but I
you know you got to plead guilty and
yeah we'll we'll try to argue diminished
responsibility but the mom was not
having it and she fired him and
apparently the dude was like relieved
because he didn't want to have to defend
this [__] whatever he found out
from the thing
so there was that
um so yeah so like I said they did have
like a lot of physical evidence like I
said they had the blood they found in
the uh basement because like I said they
were just doing the vitamin case they
tried to I think they brought in stuff
from the other crimes but you're not
really technically supposed to do that I
think they just kind of did that as like
a little bit of background and I think
that was another thing that the defense
was trying to like argue was that oh
well you're bringing in all these uh
details from these other cases and he's
not being tried for that and bloody blah
but it did kind of seem like
uh you know that the jury was kind of
like disposed toward yeah he kind of
sounds like he's guilty you know what I
mean uh so the trial went on for 17 days
I think it went on like I said just
because you entered the guilty plea
doesn't mean that the fight's over and
you've lost
because to the defense attorneys they
say yeah we're going to plead guilty to
it but I'm going to give you the best
sentence you could possibly get so then
they're going to start doing all these
mitigating factors and try to get you a
lighter sentence right so that's really
all they can do that's all they can do
right you know I'll keep you from
getting the death penalty that kind of
zip
and the new defense attorney that they
got who was kind of like a young upstart
type of dude like from a pretty big like
famous firm and like I said the mom who
was just adamant that her baby would not
do any such thing she had remortgaged
her house to pay like this huge fee yeah
for this like real like it wasn't like
the top attorney at the place but it was
a guy that had just like some hot shot
that had just started working there that
decided to take the case it tends to be
that
well yeah it's pretty typical I mean
yeah that's your mom I get it but it's
just kind of okay well there is some
doubt they don't [__] have anybody
saying he was there there's no Witnesses
so they're gonna say oh he didn't do it
yes and she really did not think yeah
and she was like yeah right
now initially I believe his defense team
wanted to put him on the stand because
they said well he's you know a very
handsome personable uh young man and
it's like if we put him on the stand
like people will see that he's just this
normal guy and he couldn't have done
this and stuff like that however it does
seem
that when they were still doing I guess
before they do like uh before they put
you on the same like doing depositions
and [__] like that
um they said they started getting a
little bit nervous because at one point
when they were like asking him questions
and stuff that he would get on the stand
he had that role that temper like he
would get like this super super rage and
like angry and stuff and they're like
yeah we can't put this guy in the stand
like this because they were shocked at
like how his mood shifted and they
thought that would not play very well
well that first you know attorneys know
everything about how to find the truth
just and and they're good at [__]
sense and characters and [__] they just
base everything on what you tell them
and what you didn't tell them when that
first attorney got a hold of this guy he
was probably unsure didn't know anything
about the legal process and said a lot
of [__] probably that [__] pointed
towards his guilt or [__] proved his
guilt
it's just that the attorney is kind of I
don't know if he can't come out and say
what he told did that be hearsay so they
can't remember that so he's like nah man
based on everything you've said and the
[__] the questions you didn't ask and I
know you're guilty you know that's what
happened there yeah I mean just so they
were like well we can't put him on the
stand because if he flips out like that
then that's gonna look really bad yeah
so and then they went back in the
judge's Chambers like the judge and the
lawyers and him and his mom
and they went back there and nobody
knows obviously that's confidential but
it's like nobody knows what was said in
the judge's Chambers but they did say
that when they all came out uh the mom
was crying and Collins was crying so and
then at that point the attorneys were
like yeah we're not putting him on the
stand so they don't know if he like
actually confessed yeah I did that [__]
or what they don't know what happened
back there but they were like yeah we're
not putting them in the sand and then at
that point they're like okay defense
rests you know what I mean there was
that
so you know then there were the closing
arguments and they both try to like say
oh it's you know oh all the witnesses
that saw him it's like it wasn't him it
was another guy that looked like him and
blah blah he had like some Alibis but it
turned out later that he had tried to
get his roommate to say because him and
his roommate had been out on this
particular day that this girl got
murdered
um like when she got picked up from the
wig shop but he tried to make the
um roommate say that they had been doing
the [__] earlier that they had been
doing it and at first he went along with
it but then like later on when they got
him talking he's like no it was more
like way later in the afternoon so he
didn't have an alibi like for the time
that she disappeared you know what I
mean so they did get him to like fess up
to that and he and the fact that he
tried to get his roommate to say oh tell
the police that we were doing this [__]
at this time that's a little sauce you
know they were there fighting over the
law now yeah you can fight him over the
law all day long lawyers do and uh you
know laws and legality is is right there
along with Holy Scripture okay
there's a bunch of it and it all depends
upon your interpretation and they can
interpret and reinterpret things to get
any kind of viewpoint well I'm gonna
look at it this way you told me this but
if I look at it from this way you didn't
tell me that you know it's it's they do
[__] like that
yeah they're just trying to get a
verdict they're trying to they're trying
to fight they're fighting with words and
Concepts and [__]
like you would like like religious
people would fight over
the interpretation of some kind of Holy
Scripture because it's all just kind of
vague and open to it sure sure yeah but
I mean at least like laws and stuff like
that like do actually exist so it's not
exciting exists but then they fight over
them well yeah because there's different
ways of coming out [__] like everybody
kind of has them although this is the
this is a special case vast majority of
legal cases are [__] open and close
because they involve [__] fines and
it's [__] like [__] zoning and [__]
like that you know they're not criminal
that's boring even the criminal shit's
boring yeah most of it [__] like this
then they start yeah why do you think
nobody wants to do jury duty yeah
but yeah so like I said he never did
take the stand
um the defense wanted to put on the same
but they were concerned because they
thought that he would look bad because
he had like this rage problem
uh and they thought that that would make
him look guilty so they advised him not
to and after he discussed some [__] with
his mom and his lawyers and the judge in
the Chambers uh they decided not to put
him on the stand at the end they all
came out crying and [__] like that so we
don't know what they said but you can
probably imagine now so the jury
deliberated three days and then
unanimously uh voted him guilty first
degree murder and this like I said this
is just the one murder because that was
what they had the most evidence for
he uh proclaimed his innocence though
said I didn't even know her I didn't do
it blah blah but but because Michigan
did not have I don't know if it has the
death penalty now but it certainly
didn't then uh so he got sentenced to
life in prison now he went through a
bunch of appeals like I said he changed
his name to John Norman Chapman uh he
wanted to get transferred to Canada for
whatever reason uh because he would have
gotten parole like after a little bit of
time but they shot that down he got um
transferred to I think three or four
different prisons like over the years he
actually did try to Tunnel out of one of
them but was not successful
but as of this recording he is still
alive and is still in prison in northern
Michigan uh now the state of California
did think about extraditing him for the
murder of Roxy Phillips because they're
pretty sure he did that [__] too when he
was over there on vacation but by the
time that this trial went through
they're like well we don't really know
how much you know public interest would
be served by that we're pretty sure he
did it but you know it just probably
wouldn't be worth anyone's time to like
bring him out here and [__] try him
again for this [__] so they didn't
so as it stands this is kind of [__]
up
um but so he was just convicted of the
one murder so I guess technically he's
not really considered a serial killer
because he was only convicted of one
murder even though he's probably
responsible for the other six but
because he wasn't convicted of those six
those six murders are still officially
considered unsolved even though they're
pretty sure he did them so there's that
um as I said his family have continued
to support him and he continues to
maintain his innocence now as I said the
one murderer Jane mixer
um was actually uh they caught the guy
that did that later on not until 2005.
they caught the guy in 2005. uh his name
was Gary leiterman
and he when they caught him he was 62
years old he was a nurse at the time of
the murder
um and he was the one that had uh killed
her like I said they figured it out with
the DNA they reopened the case in 2001
did a DNA and it was a match
on the um stockings like of the victim
so he got uh convicted of that so they
so the one murder that was kind of a
little bit different where she was just
shot and left on the gravestone and she
wasn't like mutilated or anything
they're pretty sure that was like a
different dude he shot her and left her
on a gravestone yeah and then she also
was had tied around her neck some
stockings that weren't hers right yeah
like a nylon stocking that one yeah
where did you find that don't know he
just maybe had it in his [__] truck
who knows you know
but yeah so they killed her the stocking
or the shot or the shop to the head I'm
pretty sure the shot did good but yeah
uh so yeah so that one wasn't Collins
they don't think but the other ones
allegedly pretty sure they were I mean
they were very similar and he seems like
after he was out taken off the street
that too yeah that too
like I said he's still alive I don't
know if he's seeing this now but no no
he's he's locked up
I think he better not he'd probably let
him have internet access
so Michigan's not is uncivilized it's
like Canada
they probably let them have [__]
phones cell phones in prison and the
internet
I mean if you didn't do anything that
bad I don't see why you wouldn't be able
to but these kind of [__] no
you should you should just be thrown in
a hole yeah you know what I mean
especially if they're never gonna who
knows maybe give him a [__] cell
phone and internet is an easier way to
control them keep them Placid
yeah you might have a point there yeah
so maybe getting some video games or
something yeah one blow off some steam
just let him get maybe they wouldn't get
in trouble then because then yeah like
yeah because if you kind of just like
let them sit in there and like [__]
stew then they're gonna get it look at
what's doing to these regular young guys
in their [__] 20s and 30s they're
just sitting around playing video games
getting fat then you want to go outside
just [__] do that to a [__] comic and
then they then feed them bugs like oh
[__] what's his name said you will
eat the bugs and all that kind of [__]
Ben said hang on if you got 20 years in
1970 why is he still in prison he had
life in prison it was 20-year minimum
but it was a life sentence essentially
so yeah he's still in there yeah life
without parole they're not gonna let
that [__] out not gonna let that [__]
like I said he tried to like scam and
like oh I want to be in prison in Canada
I don't know why changing his name
would have
allowed him to go to Canada and just but
I don't know it didn't work like
whatever he was trying to do I don't
know if they thought that he'd be
somebody else or feel like I don't know
if he's fooling anybody you're not
fooling anybody
somebody earlier said that he um named
himself after Mark David Chapman
he's that guy that shot um okay uh John
Lennon okay
then he shot John Lennon right Mark
David Chad that happened after this case
though wait a minute
no yeah but he didn't change his name
until later okay right right okay oh and
Ben said it was also his uh mother's
maiden name okay so maybe it was just a
maybe it was just a coincidence but yeah
so this [__] yeah hopefully he's
not gonna be alive much longer because
maybe an old man by now holy [__] yeah I
saw a recent picture of it like 70s he
looks like a grizzled old man yeah but
yeah this is what's this little [__]
up case told you and I'm just like
surprised that more people haven't heard
about it prison sucks the life Adam oh
well can't feel too bad about it I feel
like they did not gonna lie yeah pretty
much all right so are you ready to wrap
it up you seem like here oh we're gonna
get something to eat yeah yeah we've
been on a while we've been on for almost
three hours but yeah
so hopefully you guys uh like not sure
if enjoyed is the right word but yeah
hopefully you guys were interested by
this topic um like I said which I found
very interesting even though it's very
[__] up so be sure to come back by on
Friday night for our Side Tracks show
which is always fun where we just drink
and talk about random [__] that's
always a good time
so yeah
um thanks everybody like share subscribe
give us super thanks give us all that
kind of stuff and we will see you guys
again on Friday night
good